this is Jocko podcast number 361 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
in March of 1969 the Rand Corporation a
semi-private think tank that specialized
in research and Analysis for the
Department of Defense published a report
titled the Navy SEAL Commandos a case
study of military decision making and
organizational change
as far as I know the first academic
level study of the SEAL Teams the
report's author was Francis J Bing West
a former Force Recon Marine in Vietnam
War veteran whose investigation had
begun a year earlier and whose research
had produced a raft of documents dozens
of interviews and the first-hand
observation of several seal missions
into the rung sat and Mekong Delta
from this research West had produced an
18-page report whose introduction
provided a brief description of SEAL
training training he estimated at a cost
of around fourteen thousand dollars per
man plus an overview of the Seal's
commitment to Vietnam at its height a
commitment that never exceeded 150 SEALS
or roughly
1150 fewer than the in-country height of
the Green Berets total complement
it was a commitment that stood out and
even Starker relief when placed next to
the author's obvious admiration for the
seals progression from lackluster
Coastal Raiders to the war's most
aggressive direct action Commandos
admittedly Commandos who had had no
business becoming such and thus had
drawn the interest of the same
preeminent think tank that it created
the US military's nuclear defense
strategy
intended as a study on organizational
change the report's true purpose had
been to discover how the Navy could have
possibly succeeded in creating a
land-focused Commando force a force that
even the Viet Cong had reportedly dubbed
the men with green faces a color not
normally associated with the Navy's
traditional medium
it was a puzzle of personal importance
to the author as the Marine Corps the
far more likely branch of service had
never succeeded in creating anything
similar
ultimately the author decided the most
important factor in the Seal's
infringement was owing to the seals
themselves and the culture that weighed
upon them
drawn from a notoriously selective
training program that produced few
qualified candidates the seals naturally
had had to find a mission that kept
casualties low a circumstance that might
have pushed them like the lerps or the
force Recon Marines into a
reconnaissance role had they had anyone
to pass the intelligence to
they hadn't nor had there been any great
pressure from the riverine force to
engage in any sort of Green Beret style
advisory Duty or Civic action
organizational orphans with no larger
Force to support or control them and
possessing no love or admiration for the
Vietnamese the seals had set out into
the swamps not to prove themselves
they're training had already done that
said the author but
because not to go would have been
inexcusable to the others
they had developed a collective value
system which emphasized physical
hardiness and courage
and they liked to fight
so when the tactics of Patrol and Ambush
had proved unproductive nobody not a
seal meaning no Blue Water Superior
officer had ordered them to try
something else
they had just done it
what strikes me as most remarkable about
the seal Story the author concluded is
there performance and their ability to
learn and adapt in a decentralized
sub-optimizing environment
the Navy's traditional latitude and the
udt's traditional adaptability created
what several unidentified seals soon
described to a documentary filmmaker as
the war's unsung Soldier and what we
consider without question the best
troops that the country has
both descriptions notable because they
didn't use the word sailors
and just short of the Reader's Digest
appraisal that had dubbed them the wars
super Commandos
by the end
these would be assessments
that were next to impossible to dispute
and that right there is a little excerpt
from
the book by water beneath the walls a
book written by Ben Milligan he's been
on the podcast a couple times he's a
former seal and this is
indisputably speaking of indisputably
this is the best book about the history
and the emergence of the SEAL Teams
that's ever been written
and that section that I just read is
from a section of the book called
culmination
which is where the roots of the SEAL
Teams
finally grew into what we ultimately
became from our Frogman forefathers it
was in Vietnam
where the seals proved their metal
as a maritime direct action force
and it is an honor to have one of those
Vietnam eraseals here with us tonight Mr
Gill Espinoza to share his experiences
and Lessons Learned
Gil thanks for joining us good evening I
heard you uh I heard you kind of smiling
at some of those descriptions to that in
this book with what was going on yeah it
was it's uh
it's kind of interesting of how they I
think even he looks at us he's in the
teams he looks at us but every Frogman
has his own way that he looks at things
every single one of us right and uh and
I'm just thinking about other people you
know they say even Roger right his whole
his whole mindset and how he looks at it
can be totally different you know and
even operational yeah even combat you
get done doing something and years later
you're bullshitting with somebody and
it's kind of like no we didn't do that
we did this no not I'm sure it
was General no I think it was Tax
Collectors you know are you sure and the
whole history right yeah and then you
have a guy who goes
was it generals or was it tax collectors
and another teammate go well that cow
wasn't even there so some of our stories
I think some of our stories get
conflicted with other people's stories
but you do remember the ones that were
that were specifically yours that came
from here and we're talking about
the heart of the Frog man you know that
that I see where he's writing from you
know yeah no he does a great job and and
actually it's pretty incredible some of
the stuff that he documents
for instance there's a a scene where
Rangers are being overrun and he's got
quotes of as they're making Radio Calls
hey we're being overrun we need more
support God you know the the commanders
not with them and he's saying do the
best you can God speed that kind of
thing and you read it and you're
thinking oh you know he did he seemed to
have done a good job sort of sort of
coming up with what the dialogue would
be and then you read the footnote it's
not something he came up with it's
documented these are there are people
writing down the radio calls and it's
exactly what these guys said so he he's
just a very it took him seven years to
write this book uh Incredible Book
um but nothing better than the horse's
mouth and since we got the horse here
I've been trying to write a book since I
came here and thought in my head as you
know leaving Vietnam or being on the
fire department and wrestling in college
I mean the whole thing of coming back
home and looking back into where it all
began
from being a little boy well let's get
into it where did it begin let's let's
start at the beginning well
well you can tell I'm not as big as how
cool are you right and then when you you
go to class you look around I mean look
at guys like you and I went what the
hell are you doing here right but as a
little kid I was raised in Boulder
move from Rocky Ford where I was a
little kid
to Boulder and I left all my family my
grandma's my aunts my all my cous
everybody everybody in my family and
we're moving to Boulder someplace I
never knew and this is with your my mom
and dad your mom and dad right I'm like
well what made them decide to move
um economics they actually were migrant
workers My dad became a circle
contractor and then later on it just got
really really hard and we had an uncle
that owned a barber shop up in Boulder
so if the family moved where the family
was right this just like now right
everybody moves to where you have
somebody to to get a foothold in
and uh
so
in kindergarten this kid beat me up
right so my brother I'm kind of whining
and my brother said what happened what's
up I said all that guys John and Maya
beat me up John Mia I know his brother
you know so they dragged me to his place
and my brother was my hero when I was
like five years old one five years old I
was doing chin-ups when I remember when
I was one you'd hang me on the door and
walk out and leave me he'd come around
and I and I got to her on one or two and
finally I look around and I remember I
was like three or four I could get my
elbow up on the door right and he'd have
me doing chin UPS we had a rope for a
swing he had me climbing up that rope
when I was five when I was five I could
what year is this so this is like 1953
or 19th because you were born in what
1947 47 yeah so yeah so I was five years
old it was 53. so your brother had your
older brother had like a a early start
on the physical culture yeah he was
arrested oh so he was arrested he was a
wrestler and then when he went to
Boulder he's kicking the hell out of the
guys in Boulder but they were still the
underlying racist stuff and so what and
so what are you you're you're Native
American well from the pickiest people
in my grandma's pick grease but we
identified mainly as Spanish right okay
not Mexicano not Mexican because our
people did not come up from Mexico they
came from
you know Spain from Spain from through
California then to New Mexico through
establishing through the Spanish land
grants and then with the mestizos right
the Native Americans the Blended but
Blended culture right and so then
everything subsistence living then the
government comes in and says you got to
pay taxes it was all subsistent so how
are they going to pay taxes when they
never really made any money but you
would trade 10 chickens for a
for a cow or whatever I mean there was
also they were doing old school barter
old school barter and then they had to
sell their land and then move
and my my dad's family had some Spanish
land grant stuff so his stepfather my
dad's dad died when he was like baby
my dad says the government came in and
gave all the men shots dip jury shots
and you know guys died
and so they moved and uh got up to Rocky
Ford and stabbed himself as a community
my all my cousins lived on one block
there was my uncle my grandma my other
Uncle my always lived on one block
and literally there was a train track in
the back of my yard
and and there was one you know it was
kind of like a cul-de-sac that went out
to a main road and on the other side was
a ditch water
smelled kind of like a Mekong man
so when I was in Vietnam I said that
well it kind of smells you know kind of
smells like that so I was between the
railroad track and a river right and we
were always told don't play on the
tracks and don't play on the river
six five years old we had a pipe that
went across that river right it's a slow
man it's a slow ditch
our deal of manhood or whatever it was
as cousins were all about the same age
was to go across the ditch hanging
upside down growing up none of us know
how to swim
but that's where I'm getting to the
point of being the young boy little boy
right
no fear you don't have that until
somebody tells you don't go into the
ditch you're gonna drown you don't know
what drowning is until somebody until
you do want a bit of swimming pool and
you go Jack could drown right but you
don't have that fear
you know you don't you don't know that
you're you don't know that you're black
you don't know that you're Brown you
don't know that you're white you don't
know any of that stuff you're a kid
right intelligent loving caring that
Natural Curiosity and zest for life that
powerful person as a little boy well I
got my ass kicked by John a mile right
you didn't know you'd get your ass
oh yeah I had climbing ropes I was
having a good time I'm a kid and I think
all kids are like that right initially
we're all they're all like that and so
my brother takes me over there and he
says
had this kid come out he always said his
brother they come out and I'm like
you know in order to maintain that part
that your intelligent loving caring with
that Natural Curiosity exists for life
you're having these natural
physiological releases which are
laughing talking crying shaking sweating
yawning and all that stuff right to keep
that to keep that and to keep that
intact right
so I'm going through all that stuff with
my brother I had a Warrior brother right
he wanted to make sure he knew I was
going to get my ass kicked when I was a
kid so he took because I'm sure it
happened to him but he was my older
brother I didn't know that how much
older was he then nine years old oh dang
so that's a big spread so he's a real
like hero too oh man yeah
he's a chief retired Navy chief he went
to the Navy how do I wound up in the
Navy
so this kid comes out and my brother
looks and he goes now remember remember
that little he showed me a duck under
right a duck under and a high crotch and
a throw he said just do that
we'll go because I mean I couldn't
really do it with my brother but he
would show me
so all right so I came up the kid come
underneath I grabbed me something with
duck under threw him threw him down he
says and when you throw him down sit on
him and make him say uncle
I mean that was a rule of the old days
right threw them down say uncle you know
okay I'll go my brother you know then he
says don't ever
don't ever let anybody you know don't
let your brother mess around anybody
mess with my brother you just let him
know I've got his back so I go to school
back to Liberty right grade's going
Rocky Ford and everybody
watch out for that little guy you know
they call me Tuffy you know I didn't
know
so then when we left Rocky Ford I'm
crying all the way from Rocky Ford to
Boulder and my dad
gets tired of it he says God
he stopped at the Overlook you ever been
to Boulder Colorado
no when you come down into it it's
beautiful I didn't so I'm crying my dad
grabs me
pulls upside the road gots me and throws
me in the back I don't know if I'm going
right as we were coming over this hill
I'm thinking I don't have anybody that
aloneness of being alone like when you
start training right or you go in the
Navy where you feel that you're alone or
anytime that you left Islands right
and for a little boy to be alone that
that was the beginning of being a frog
man I look at it now right and so when
we came over I looked
I peeked up because he threw me in the
back of the truck got tired of me being
inside
in here
and I think the thing is we those of us
who are introspective or really
searching for what is who we are right
that little boy is always who we were
but it gets covered up by all the
well when I went over and I
looked
I saw these mountains and in my heart I
heard no we're here and we'll be your
friends forever and it was a squander
Brave I look at him I could see the
Silhouettes of him I went and I looked
down and I saw the shiny lights
in a
it's the same thing that I got when I
saw Point Loma when I was going to
Vietnam right and I saw Point Loma and
and the finger is pointing
that way to Vietnam right but when I
when I sensed that I went
Okay so I go to school and
Boulder and a goddamn Charlie mess this
beats me up the first day
you know and my brother I was like uh
seven or seven or eight and I didn't
want to tell my brother because I didn't
you know I didn't want to go didn't want
him to set up another prize fight for
you right and so I got my ass kicked for
five days
figuring it out and that's when I
understood the inside Warrior
the inside was the one that talks to you
that goes boom you get hit here and it's
kind of like figuring stuff out it's
like your first wrestling match or
Jujitsu or your first appointment right
and I felt that that's what I was doing
I was I was sensing and understanding it
and
then one day the outside Warrior came in
he came I grabbed all to Charlie man I
hit him with that high cross and dropped
him down you know and just started two
times in my life that time when I
started beating him badly another time
when I came back from Vietnam and got in
a fight with a guy it felt like and you
never see the Patriot you know when uh
he hacks up that guy that kills his son
when I saw that movie I started crying
because that's the way I felt right
that's totally not out of control you
don't ever have these flashbacks where
you're totally out of control and it's
always calc it's always the on the
inside the outside Warrior always
understands what's happening and what
he's doing it's just that when does he
feel like stopping and the inside
Warrior says that's enough
but they both cover up the little boy
because a little boy would have never
wanted to have that fight in the first
place he wants to be a little kid so
rather than asking myself and I did ask
myself what's wrong with me
that's not even the question
the question is
what's wrong with Charlie
why why is he was he jacked up you know
and then later on I kind of became
Charlie but when you find out that you
can wrestle and you're a pretty tough
guy then you're picking on guys that you
know you shouldn't even be picking on
but they don't know how to wrestle
they're big guys they don't know how to
wrestle but you do
so
I
I won that fight and then what happens
another guy named Terry Fox big guy you
want to beat the hell out of me so I'm
like what the hell trying to figure this
out and that was the very first time
that an ally came in he was Mike
Martinez and he said hey man he says
he's too little for you to fight it's
when you fight me
I understood allies
you know and uh so I called him Uncle
Mike
and let everybody know use my ears what
grade are you in at this point that one
that wasn't that was in second grade
damn you know so so that happened
so that was my life right and uh
and then I came into this group it's
called got Street neighborhood right it
was right after the war we were all born
in 47 most of us
the poor whites
the Jews the blacks that worked on the
radio on the on the train
um the Polish the guys left over from
from World War II the Mexicanos and a
couple Japanese guys right
this is your neighborhood that was my
neighborhood on God Street in Boulder
right so when people say it takes it
takes a village to raise a child that's
because it takes
if I've went and not picked up something
that wasn't mine Miss Toledo sitting on
the front porch is that yours
no man don't put the goddamn thing down
you put it down or you're cutting school
what are you guys doing over here I mean
you know are you supposed to be in
school yeah so there was always this my
mom said what were you doing over there
I'm going
I wasn't there lying right away you know
kind of like going through SEAL training
man you start lie cheat still do
whatever you can do to get through this
training but don't get caught right
Oliver and chief Allen don't get caught
that's Miss Toledo and Miss Martinez and
Mr vanities you know don't get caught
and then when you got caught my mama
how do you know that it says
little bird told me
so I'm like who in the hell is this
little bird it's a little bird called a
rat it was all of them you know but that
was that neighborhood of caring people
that really care about you about what's
going on not because you're Mexicans or
not because you're Spanish not because
you're white because this is your
neighborhood this is where you belong
this was my and and it isn't an identity
thing it's a belonging thing that you
know they're invested in in you and and
that there was all of us are going to go
to school
we're all not going to cut school there
was a black guy and we and we had to
give up our language those of us were
Spanish right
don't speak Spanish in school so we're
getting ready to go to school
um well this is in high school but but
in junior high it was it was the same
thing I go to Junior High
who's this guy Nick Crispin right
the badass kid in school the 9th grader
and I'm seventh grade little
um
a bit of this kid I don't even know that
kid well if you don't beat him up I'll
beat you up
it's just like ah
so I don't want to get beat up so I beat
up a kid that I beat him up
and so then but then what happens inside
right that heart that that thing that
comes in goes this isn't right
so I went up to to the guy and said hey
look man
I said we might as well fight now
because I'm not going to do that again
oh no you're cool you're cool
and I inside I was crying because I beat
up a guy that I didn't and Oh no you're
cool and so then I understood a bully I
understood what they're going to make me
do if I don't make a choice right
so I go through that I go to the
bathroom
next was a guy named Nick this guy named
Chuck and this guy named rich I won't
say their last names because they're all
dead but I don't really like those guys
anyway
so I'm in there taking the leak and the
guy comes in and
say what are you doing here now look up
and says uh oh
seventh grade right it's this innocence
right the Innocence
and uh
I said so who are you I said I'm I'm
good Espinoza oh yeah I said who are you
guys well we're here to beat the
out of you I'm like
come on man I'm so little I'm so little
it's about like this I was like four
foot I was small I was smaller than her
lips shorter than Herbie crowd here we
were out that's why he and I are we're
good buddies because we're both little
guys because they're little guys in the
teams for sure and then there are little
guys in the teams in big guys big little
guys like Kirby Pharrell's a big little
guy you know there are other ones that
are you know they're like you guys were
shrunk down I was a skinny guys
120 pounds you know carrying 90 pounds
of gear up in the up in the maqua up and
when I was working with the with the
crews and working with the Vietnamese
seals I carried on an M60 with 800
rounds when we went heavy on the border
right
so
and so
so what happened to so do you fight
these guys also then what happened this
guy Bruce McDowell steps in he was from
Hawaii
and he steps in and he goes what's going
on in here and I'm going those guys
would have beat me up and he goes oh
here's we see Hey guys you're way too
big for him but the little necks he
looked at me he's really cool he says
if I stay here
you want to fight that little guy
and I'm already
I'm shaking man I got tears in my eyes
I'm like I'm alone and you're in seventh
grade I'm in seventh grade I'm alone
and uh all the guys from God Street we
we came to school together we didn't
realize that the classism was happening
there's classism and racism right well
the classism took all of his poor people
together right
didn't matter whether you're right or
whatever that was they called our street
Sin City we didn't even know until we
were already men we didn't know that
that's what they called our neighborhood
and so
hey going yeah he says well okay so I
hit him with that move man high cries
come around boom hit him put him in the
urinal and next thing you know I
outside Warrior was working man it was
high order right I love the word high
order when winning the teams man because
that means you're high order it's a high
order detonation I mean that was in it I
took him I put his head in the toilet
and I sat on his back and started
flushing it and I was screaming you know
like when when you when you're in the
cold water that whole thing yeah you
know just
keeping your together right I'm
screaming next thing I'm
picked up out of the of this guy Bruce
McDowell takes me over excuse me in the
corner
it's breathe and I'm like
you know Breezy tells those guys get the
hell out of here and I'm like and so he
says hey he says uh it's a calm you know
let's come down like breathe and I'm
breathing he says uh
hey this is uh did you ever wrestle I
wrestle my brother taught me Russell
move but he went in the Navy and I'm I'm
alone
he said look wait a minute wait a minute
so did you ever think about wrestling we
have a wrestling team here
so no he said well and you and you'll be
wrestling guys your size not big guy
little guys your size so you gotta come
out maybe right so that yeah and that
was the beginning of another Evolution
right so I went to wrestle but I found
out I was wrestling
I was wrestling for all the wrong
reasons
I was wrestling to learn how to fight
wrestling learned how to protect myself
to wrestling so that I didn't have to if
the bully came I didn't have to
bow down to him that I didn't have to
serve anybody
though seems like actually good reasons
for me to wrestle you said those are the
wrong reasons I don't know as far as I'm
Richard I tell kids to wrestle all the
time and I tell them you're gonna be
able to take care of yourself you can
get good shape I'm like those good
reasons those are good reason why I
wasn't happy doing it you know what I
mean got it there are kids that are
happy they love the sport and all that
was a two-time state champion I took
fourth one as a sophomore do I every
once go out there hey yeah you know run
around all the stadium and everybody's
sci-fi in me I'm like well there's one
down here but next year's the next year
and every son of a gonna have to wrestle
I'm gonna kick the out of everybody
until they know I'm there
and so that's the two two things right
ego
and heart
and you're what you want
right what do I do them out of a lot of
us went into teams out of the ego thing
those cats were the swimmers and all
that kind of stuff
they were successful because they beat
guys who were the same as them and they
happen to have a little bit more Talent
so they win
but was the ego was at heart
when you're a wrestler and you go out
there and you're getting your ass beat
every day like I had so much respect for
the kids that weren't as good as I was
but showed up for practice for me every
day and I'd and I'd make them hurt I'd
make him cry because that's where I was
getting my stuff right my wrestling
coach was a UDT guy right so what was
his name Harold Ashton Brenner he helped
start the um the museum in in uh Fort
Pierce so was he a World War II guy or
Korea guy okay in the gap of Korea and
Vietnam right actually Russell Campbell
who wrote the book was Rusty Campbell is
called Seal Team
was with his instructor
he didn't even know how to swim either
he had to walk on the bottom of the pool
carrying rocks until he learned how to
swim that's the other thing about the
teams a lot of these guys didn't they
didn't swim well they swam long but they
didn't swim well there were other guys
that could Mouse number one swim pair
without fins you put fins on me I went
to number 10 and those guys with big big
legs yeah they kicked up and they
were number one I'm out there freezing
in the water you know but so so you get
so you figure out about wrestling and
did was there a wrestling team at in
seventh grade Yeah well yeah okay so you
immediately or very soon after you you
you started actually wrestling yeah I
just actually started wrestling and now
you started to learn and you took to it
really well yeah I did yeah and I think
of my brother but there was always that
that thing you know
and wait one thing the thing of I want
to be able to protect myself I want to
be able to kick people's asses yeah and
it was a little bit more ego driven
maybe survivals survival I was gonna say
maybe just protection of of like well
like you said not wanting to about have
to bow down to people right yeah
so yours your brother had joined the
Navy yeah and what year did he join the
Navy in 56
and on that wrestling see he was on
Boulder High wrestling team that I
eventually went to but he was kicking
the out of the doctor's son so they
said he had a heart murmur
and and what they wouldn't let him
wrestle they wouldn't let him wrestle
but when my brother went into the Navy
he had no heart murmur my brother was a
corpsman he finished up over here with
Seal Team right and in Vietnam he was he
was working medevax
a couple Seal Team guys got hit I'm
there at the same time we're both
Vietnam same time right in 69. and uh he
was 67 or 68 and in part of 69. and he's
sitting there checking all these guys
out you know the helicopter bring him in
he said I started looking at it I
couldn't tell anybody all looked alike
right he says then I thought what the
hell am I doing looking at these my
brothers like this
he's a Kirby Morel you know he's a
little guy all these guys you know the
guys he because they it wasn't just the
guy's wounded but they all she actually
did the extrication right so they just
they flew him out
so he was a corpsman in it it got him so
did you at what point did you start
thinking about joining the Navy
well
my brother went in the Navy and so here
I am
when I graduated when I when I came back
from Vietnam I'd been back about 10
years I thought a Herald Ashen burner
so I called him up
hey do you remember I was 103 pound
state champ man 95 and 103 pounds when I
went into the teams I went about 112
pounds 115. a little that's crazy and
there's still two guys littler to me the
Waller Wonder Brothers they're they're
in team two or something like that and
um
there was like Mike Walsh she wrote a
book Mike Walsh is about might like me
but he's
he's about like I am now when he went
when he went through you know I weigh
more than I did then you were 112 pounds
in buds yeah that's freaking crazy that
was 120 pounds when when I got burned it
went in Vietnam after the the water and
all that stuff
carrying 90 pounds a gear trying to keep
up with everybody but I was selling them
water
because I drink water and they're
sweating and stuff you don't need any
water I didn't need water and wrestlers
don't need one because in those days we
you know we uh drank we didn't drink any
water and we took salt tablets right
before practice all this stuff to kill
you right so I had a big triangular
water bath you know so I'd sit there and
we'd be operating uh ask me you got some
water yeah and they were all outranked
me so I had them in the water and they'd
take drinks and they'd count the
swallows one two the three bucks five
bucks
you know so I'd make money on patrol and
then I'd borrow money from them because
I didn't have any money when we were in
Pennsylvania they kind of balanced out
you know
but uh so so you get to high school is
did you play any other sports besides
cross country okay so you're a good
runner I was a good runner I was too
late to play football on a lightweight
football team but when we played in The
Green Field I mean just no pads no
nothing I was one of the fastest runners
and I'd hit you so hard I'd almost knock
myself out so so they didn't want to
come around the corner because I don't
want to come past me and and we would
have we would play football in that
football would eventually turn it into a
fight you're gonna fight somebody right
and I they wouldn't with me too much
because I was a good wrestler you know
but uh
are you getting good grades I was
struggling with my grades I didn't
understand and that's why when my kids
when they're growing up I said well how
do you teach
because I found I'm more of a more of a
Hands-On learner right a visual learner
so Concepts that I would get in my mind
it'd be kind of hard I found that out
when I went through training
all the I needed everything I
needed to know the the dive physiology
anatomy and all that I was kind of
struggling with that right but I got it
because I it was the body right triceps
biceps heart and all that that was I dug
that right
but
the demolitions right Mark 23 mod 1
Bangalore torpedo hbx rate of fire is
this and that I'm going oh shoot it took
the first test I already gone through
already gone through hell week I already
went through dive phase I already went
through everything hell week was a trip
but
I learned that because you know
um Crawford okay so I'm I'm sitting
there struggling senior class yeah it's
my class crowd Daddy hey we were in the
same boat crew in hell week he told me a
story about hell week that I did that I
didn't know that I did but he remembered
it I didn't he was my EXO when I checked
into team one oh really yep I love him
yep I think I might even giving him that
name crawdad I even changed the other
guy's name from John to Jonah and he
still goes by Jonah but um yeah I he
said what
what's going on I said man and I'm sad
uh two guys died out there before San
Clemente in my training class right
so these guys that drowned get uh hung
up on a um yeah on a Scully yeah
girl call him a call
so yes what's going on it says Hey cry I
said I'm gonna they're gonna drop me so
why it's like that the demolition status
so he came over just a piece of paper
says okay write down man and that was
just old Barracks man we had to under
under a blanket with a flashlight
Mark 133 mod 1 133 mod 2. Bangalore
torpedo H all of the demolitions that we
were going to be tested on
I wrote them every night for a week
every night on a piece of paper since
that's what that's what it's all about
I said okay and then what they were used
for right so I go take my test
okay you guys got one hour to get your
test done
so I grabbed my piece of paper and I
start writing it out and start to come
by Spinoza says you got an hour I said I
know
you got an hour
as I know
just looking so then he walk
takes off right and I got it done so
then what I could do is I could take
that paper I could look at it see the
question
read the question look at the answers
answers right there
but for me to get it you know and then
when I went to college you wanted
well that's a whole another that's later
but
I didn't believe I graduated you know
with the 3.95 you know I want to be a
teacher right but there's the reasons I
wasn't a teacher but
um so I understood that was my way of
learning but it took so in high school
you weren't doing great no no but you
graduated what year did you graduate
high school it's
66 65 and then I went to Navy in 66.
what'd you do in the in between well in
between time in between time I had a
wrestling scholarship to University of
Northern Colorado Okay so well actually
Northeastern junior college so I was
wrestling right
I went home on break
walked into this bar and one of the
wrestlers that was one of my heroes name
was Johnny manzanaris from Lafayette he
was just went to Junior College he was a
tough guy
so
but go back to Harold right yes
he says did you ever uh go into teams I
said yeah I said you remember what I
asked you're going to do when we were in
the wrestling room you know like when
you're wrestling you all just kind of
laying around I said no he said I asked
you what are you going to do when you
get on get out of college out of high
school
and uh you said well I'll go into the
Navy
and then I asked you coach asked me what
makes you think you're man enough to be
a frog man and I told him Coach if
you're man enough to be a frog I know
I'm mad enough to be a frogman which is
one of those things right just one of
those things and so um
yeah I so so you said you were home on
break from your wrestling scholarship
yeah and you said did you went to a bar
you went to a bar it's called Grandma's
bar and we also tell them where are you
going I'm going to Grandma's I thought
we were going to Miss Toledo's house
right we're all going to a bar sneaking
in 17 years old but I I was in college
right you know as a freshman
walked in and I see my buddy uh Ronnie
manzanaras hey man how you doing it's
like from Lafayette they used to go
wrestlers from Louisville Lafayette
would go to Boulder and we'd wrestle
because we're all in three different
leagues and we prepare ourselves for the
state tournament right because we're all
and that's when we really knew that we
were state champions because we could
whip those guys and they were state
champions 1A and 2A so this is I'm the
real champ you know and so yeah it was
um
how you doing man he says uh start
crying wait what's up man you okay
they killed my brother
what
they killed Johnny he was the Big Red
One Man Small Arms you know
and I grabbed it was the first time that
I lost somebody from there from my
family from you know when you talk about
family it's just big
and uh from from Louisville Lafayette
Latinos
and hugged him and we cried and then we
sat down and let me beer and said yeah
and pretty soon he was telling stories
about his brother
and we were all laughing and crying and
and everything so then I went after
Christmas break I went back to school
and I was wrestling real well on it I
was doing real well
and when I went
it was just like I had to tell the coach
I said I'm not coming back
this is why not I said I can't if you
think about I was raised when President
Kennedy got assassinated right that's
not what your country can do for you but
what you can do for your country I
always felt that my brother was serving
in the military my uncles were in World
War II right uncles that were in Korea
and uh we all served in the military
and uh
so then it was like what am I doing here
wrestling which wasn't real
trying to get laid
and my friends are dying
so I said I'm
joined the Navy but there was the other
side of that my brother had gone around
the world so I'm going I want to go
around the world before because I'd
taken the I'd taken the test you know
UDT you know in in um in boot camp that
I passed all that
but I wanted to I wanted to party
well I got stuck on a ship in Long Beach
that's right that's where I got that
right 17 18 years old
and uh
so wait so you get to boot camp so get
to boot camp and and you so you had the
plans of going into UDT I I had the
thoughts about going UDT yeah I wanted
to be a frog man
it's just
because I'm a wrestling coach because
he's talking about the cool man
blowing stuff up and you know dropping
pick up and jumping out of airplanes and
I'm going wow that that's and then one
thing I like best of all of it man you
get to wear Aviator Shades work out lay
in the Sun and get to wear swimming
trunks and chicks dig you so I'm going
well I could do that right I used to say
man I used to be a 35 year old man that
did a put a shirt on at work unless it
was like inspection day right just never
why you know pair of shorts That's it
man pair of shorts and jungle boots and
living the dreams and we had a blue and
gold man we had the original blue and
gold yeah guys would wear the blue and
Golds off
off duty you gotta beware unless you're
uniform yeah but we would wear whatever
we wanted to wear you know so you so you
take the screening test to go to buds
yeah and boot camp I took the test in uh
I was the only guy out of my whole
company that passed one other guy went
with me but he had false teeth so he
about drowned he didn't make it so so
then when so then when I really decided
to do it because I was on the ship man I
got tired of as a machinist mate
stinky we did our sea trials and all
that stuff in the hole and everything
like that but even then I was doing
chin-ups on the steam deals and I was
doing push-ups I'd I'd go work out by
myself on why are you doing that stuff
part of it was the wrestling thing part
of it is
right it's always there that's
that's part of it was your brother
hanging you off of a door when you were
four years old
there was part of that I mean he's stuck
you know and and if you think about it
when you're doing that stuff that is the
time that you're revealing yourself to
yourself
that that little boy you're always and
when I'm doing that even now what worked
out over over at the amphib base
I can I can I I feel the young boy I
feel the little boy coming up I feel
that that spirit of peace that I have
that is Young then that is strong even
even got a jacked up shoulder I got a
left knee replacement my ankle I'm
looking at that you know it's uh and so
yeah it was uh
it was
I was looking at the end of that ship
and here come these guys Swimming by
because I'm sitting on that ship soon
where was that ship stationed well
stationed at a Long Beach okay so we did
you see trials and we pulled in San
Diego God so we're over on 36 over by
the bay when guys used to do the
training in the bay okay and I'm sitting
looking out there and stinky and
everything we had to help the board him
and blow the tubes so we're all black
now look and here come these guys
Swimming by yeah you know they're
heading to a keg too yeah who who are
those guys you know those are UT guys
I'm like how about this so I put in for
it and my EXO wouldn't let me go because
that's too little or you're too little
you'll never make it
God I hated I hated that sabotaging
beliefs in the time I was a kid you're
too small
right you're too dark even when I was
wrestling in high school my wrestling
coach took a team to Japan I was a
two-time state champ they didn't take me
or a guy named Joe Silva right
and I and I said well why what's the
deal
well Gil you really don't look like what
the Japanese think Americans look like
I'm like huh I didn't understand that
right what
and so the sabotaging belief like that
right is it ego or what is it but it is
something that says uh-uh you're not
going to make me beat up somebody you're
not going to make me do those things
because that little boy that's in there
knows who he is right he's being
revealed
is being revealed that was part of that
pain of hearing that was revealing
right so I'm looking at these guys
swimming so hell I'm going to do that
and that coach I mean the EXO said
you're too little or whatever next thing
you know
there I am over the training right I had
to I had to do this they took us they
said once you go down to a hyperbaric
chamber test that's okay I did that in
Long Beach
do the PT test again the run the swim
and all that stuff and then we want you
to go down to the tugboat and there's a
diver down there Class A diver
that's all right so I go down there and
there's a chief you know those old
Chiefs the diver Chiefs right the hard
hat helmet what you doing kid I said I
don't know they told me to come down I
want to go on UDT
uh oh yeah come on over here sit down so
put that the big old boots right the big
old heavy boots and they folded all the
the the was the class one Dives yeah
whatever they call it you know and then
they put the helmet on you know I'm
sitting here like this
I go over there go to the ladder go down
he says and just walk around down there
there's some eels over by some rock just
kind of make yourself at home and we'll
talk to you and check you out I said
this was your first dive ever ever for
someone ever been underwater I didn't
know anything
so I go down and it's like uh how you
doing now now so I'm doing fine this is
uh everything good I said yes well you
know there's some water coming in my
left leg you know oh yeah don't worry
about it it says water will come in your
left leg I said all right so let us know
if it goes into your right leg so a
little bit I'm still walking around it
was 15 minutes right so I'm walking out
it goes in my left leg on my right right
leg and I'm going hey you know this so
what's this this suit's leaking
yeah okay we know it don't worry about
let us know if the water gets up to your
chest I didn't know anything about
pressure right
the the pressure in the helmet's not
going to go any deeper I'm going I said
hey you know the water is up on my neck
nothing
nobody talks about hey uh the water is
up to my neck maybe you guys might think
about pulling me up
nothing
so then it was like
I'm going to die
so I went over to some rocks I laid back
on the Rocks I reached back I thought
well if I can grab the ropes if I can
grab the hose I'll put myself up but
they had it tended so there's no way I
could I could reach it
so in my mind Hail Mary full of grace
the Lord is your day I'm gonna die and
then they next thing is it's quiet I
didn't I didn't pray it out loud him
pulled me up yeah you passed kid so
about three days later and then they had
already had my orders and I show up at
the area so show up the area and I look
at guys like Echo
look at guys like Jocko I'm going the
same question like what the what am
I doing here right I'm just a little guy
I'm wandering around here and I saw
another guy Latino Gregory Garcia I
looked at him and he had said hey man
how you doing this is two little guys
good where are you from as I'm from
Fresno he's I'm from Colorado because
you speak Spanish they said no me
neither just we're like you know but
we're the only two and that was in 41
right
and so you're 112 pounds yeah that's
freaking well give me the advantage 120
pounds okay even 120 man because I'm
just there's so much physical stuff they
have to do with like Karen logs carrying
boats like yeah and so people would sit
there and say like I was under the boat
for a while and then they go oh you two
little guys me and Gregory are going to
see we're in front right and then they
got two medium-sized guys and they're
two tall guys so our boat was like this
so going to mount sierabachi was cool
because it stays level but when you come
down the other side
the first three times it wasn't good
because we would crash and then because
when we really got to run fast I mean we
just it was sprinting downhill in order
for us to make it you know so there's so
what's your introduction to buds like or
it's UDT trade how do you guys say that
udtra
what was your introduction
um when I first got there yeah like you
got there
well when it first got there was
everybody just kind of wandering around
you know it was like
this was in 41 right in 41. this is
class 41 class 41. and this is going to
share something with you that was really
painful for me in 41. and so um
there's another little guy his big mouth
man another guy and then there's another
guy black cat
beautiful yeah I'm going Jesus cravingly
man and there was another little guy um
meltanaka he graduated he's a he's a
teams
um
and um
Artie Reese I don't know if you've ever
heard of him he's another little guy
and so
you guys had a little Mafia little guy
mafia they were little guys but they
outweigh Me by about 10 pounds
but but uh it was
it was
I didn't have any Focus you know I was
just along for the ride doing whatever
they were going to do and so um
it was like there was no like this prep
stuff it was like we got there for one
week everybody kind of got to know each
other the second week we're running
we're in we're in class we're in
training and we're doing all that the
whole physical thing getting us ready
for hell week right
and so during whole week uh it was the
last day of whole week before you secure
it's a Friday afternoon it was a
Saturday they secure right
I think they secured on Saturday when
hell week is over yeah I mean yeah it's
it's been Friday and it's been Saturday
depending on like what era well it was
Friday and then that Friday night they
do a paddle and then they secure Sunday
right
so that we were doing a swim
so this is in hell week this is in hell
week okay we were doing a swim and uh
down and back down and back now and when
I got me and Gregory Lee got out we got
these guys are getting out of the water
soon all right so we I'm glad too
because it was cold we get out of the
water when we get out of the water or
chief Allen
he says okay you
if and quitter is over here and I'm like
well I didn't quit
he says you're out of the water and it
says yeah I said get back in the Water
by that time my I was cramped up there
were like about 60 guys got out I mean
almost almost the whole class got out
and so
I said I didn't quite just get in the
water and I went I couldn't I didn't
know that if I'd got back in the water
that I would have felt warm
I didn't know that so I went with
everybody else
so that night
that was Saturday night I could see him
coming around for the last paddle and I
looked out the back window
and I just started crying
because I didn't quit man so I went back
to the instructor section there was no
Bell it was on the door
Espinoza reported anyone to speak to you
Chief your Chief Allen
and uh so what do you want to Espinoza I
said Chief I didn't quit I said got out
with everybody but I didn't quit
this is your quit I said I
didn't quit
I said I won't back in he says you can't
get back in
I said I gotta get back in
is someone going to tell you this he
says there's only one way that you may
have a chance he says you got to go talk
to the captain captain Myers Commander
all I am FIB base right if the whole
command and talk to him maybe you might
have a chance he's by doubt it so what
day of hell week was this it was the
last day of Hell Week
we'd already gone through hell week
we've already gone through all the
rolling around and all that so you're
done with five days of hell week we were
in the we were in the sixth day of hell
week so it's it's pretty much over it's
pretty much over it was the last
evolution it was the swim and then we
get in boats and then we paddle right it
was late there's late in the afternoon
probably about five or six o'clock at
night or in the just you know like out
here starts starts the Sun starts coming
down so you you guys finished the swim
for those guys that finished the swim
those guys that were with me that I was
with we were out
with the ball quitters right
I couldn't I said I didn't quit in here
right
so I went and I told you fell and I said
I didn't quit he slams the door and says
get the out of here
so I went back to the barracks
and I was broken man
because I wanted to be a frog man
and so the next that was uh that was
Saturday morning Sunday came and all the
guys in the class were barely walking
and they're sitting there looking at me
you know
and uh I'm looking at them and like and
I'm sure they were seeing a
quitter you know
and uh I don't really want to say that
word but that so
that next day I put on my dress blues
man I go to it's a guy said hey ask me
where you going I said I'm getting back
into training so I went got breakfast
went over to the that
knock on the door oh well we go in
and uh these other guys said oh we'll go
with you right about 20 guys
go with me crawdad knows this story 20
guys go with me these are guys from your
class the guys are all that had made it
no that had quit okay all the Glitters
right all the all the guys that had made
it to that phase of hell week and there
were even some guys in 41 that quit
after the whole week and said forget it
see people it's just the training man
it's not the real world Ops so when
people talk about oh going through frog
man and oh yeah I did hell week and all
that but you go then you still
got to do World Ops
that's that's what they don't that's
what they don't tell you about that's
what you don't see that's what the hero
is but when you get
out like Roger Hayden does a trip with
UDT gets shot gets bronze star from
there then he goes to Seal Team and they
look at him and say
a new guy huh
tons of
I didn't do any do anything and you know
and you know Roger so he's got some big
balls to call Roger yeah he was a new
guy well he was yeah he was a new guy
I'll tell you something more about that
later on but so
I'm in there Captain walks in so did
these 20 guys that came with you did
they also want to get back into training
yes
so they all come with me right
Skipper walks in
we waiting told him what you know what
we wanted
he goes back out
the one day for five days he never
talked to us never acknowledges nothing
so from 20 to 30 guys people said
it I ain't doing this they're gone right
at the end of the end of that week there
were six of us
me shallenberger moe Steele Garcia right
and uh McGee
so the next week that that Friday he had
us come in
we came in let me see what do you want I
said and I looked I looked at the guys
you know I looked at him and says I
didn't quit sorry about what about you
guys and they just looked it was like
I didn't quit either right
six of us it says well we want to get
back into the next class
get out of my office
so we leave
weekend so the next week I show up with
the guys who will be doing this because
going back
so we go back Monday it comes in the the
whole day
we sit there he walks in walks out walks
in leaves and then he comes in the
evening he says okay he says uh
I'll see you Friday don't come in BCU
Friday so that was another week
we came in that Friday
he said I talked to your instructors
I told him who you were I asked him
about what went down and they're willing
to give you a chance
but I have a condition
we're like
okay
he says one of you quit or get hurt for
any reason
you're all gone
so I'm like
I looked at my guys I said look guys
this is important
if you don't want to do this don't do it
because
I gotta do it right
I don't want I I had a hard time being a
loser I had a hard time like letting
guys you know when they did even when I
was getting beat up the inside Warrior
is working and going now you're going to
figure it out you're gonna you're gonna
take care of this and I wanted the
chance to to push it all away right
and it was like no we're in we all
agreed right so the first day of 42.
first day of 42 Oliver comes out just
because Garcia schallenberger Steele
McGee and Moe Lester Mo he was the one
who got went out of our class that got
killed second class torpedo man
out of the six of us two of us became
seals we were drafted into Seal Team we
didn't go UDT like you just have to go
to udg training and then you go to do
tours UDT and then you volunteer for
seal right
so did you go did you re-class up did
you start with a brand new class yeah so
you went all the way back through first
phase again started all over and here
they are we're up there in front we're
front and center and they said about
face facing the class these
are quitters don't walk to
them don't talk to them don't be around
them don't hang with them because that's
who they are
so everybody's kind of looking at all
the cats are 42 right and so they put us
in the same boat crew and it was
miserable man I mean it was but me and
Garcia were the two little guys in front
and shelter and steel were a little bit
about a little bit higher and McGee and
mo were taller so our boat was pretty it
was a lot better than like this it was
kind of like this and they put they put
it on us and I look at some of the guys
like now in my class he said then they
said look over us and see what was
happening to us like well today
ain't quitting you know and
so then we get ready to go do hell week
so I'm I'm looking at my guys by the way
it takes like
months and months and months to recover
from hell week
so you had been through hell week all
the way until the last day yeah and then
you just went right back into a freaking
class then then there was like about I
don't know like there's probably about
the three weeks or something like that
and it was the next class we still had
blisters on our asses you know and our
hands were we're still jacked up so
so we're looking at each other and said
okay
this is it we're what's going to be
painful but what they did then is the
officers picked people in their classes
that's how I got wound up with crawdad
right Mr Kirkland picked me uh crawdad
uh Courtney Angelina and possult what
for like their boat crew the boat crew
there were six of us me and pastel were
two little guys and then
um Courtney and Crawford were a little
bigger and then Mr Kirkland
and uh I forgot the other guy was they
do us all by height now but we take all
the smaller guys put them together they
take all the tall guys put them together
ours were pretty much together six there
were six of us in the boat crew not
seven
and we were the number one boat crew we
won we won this year and I was a crowd
that tells the story when uh because we
did all those harassment things yeah
well I did want her to run on my knees
like this and and the guys were Chief
Allen comes out there and standing in
front of Me Knocking this around and
and you know hey guys help me
so
we as trainees right in 42 a lot of guys
think outside the box there's there's a
lot of guys in 42 but we are the ones
that challenged our instructors Oliver
sing a song ending guy right one little
two little three little Indians bang
bang
oh you thing do you you know it
sticks us out on the swimmer line right
we're out there on the swimmer line and
he goes all I need is one of you to quit
so I'm way at the back end have you all
over have me I'll have you you sons of
will be out there all night and
we were because it was you know the tide
goes in and out and then Chief Allen is
sitting there there used to be a lady
called well Wolfman Jack was one guy
that was going on he has a wolf man Jack
I'm doing Soul music and then uh there's
a lady named her sister Margaret black
lady she'd be like do you have problems
do you have pain in your heart
if you don't know what you're doing in
your life Sister Margaret call her at
355-3585 and it was like f you Sister
Margaret our guys were fighting we're
fighting back right yeah we're fighting
back for that Humanity they're we're
fighting back to reveal that that's why
42 is a pretty tight class and big
you know because
the nature of American offense the
nature of that class was set like that
and when we went through training those
guys helped me get through this
Evolution Chief Allen lost his glasses
Crawford and dad said we went out
looking for his glasses and you went
over oh I got it over here killer whale
we called him killer whale right and I
stood up and found it in the sand and I
stomped on him
damn I picked him up when I go here you
go
he looked down he goes
straightens them up put some wine goes
cool
walks off Crawford disease and his heart
fell through his ass oh my God he's
going to kill us but that's what that's
what they want your strictures aren't
there to kill you and make you they want
they want now I see it it's totally
different not break you down to make you
a lot of that's you hear a lot of these
seals right well they break you down so
he can mold you right back
I'm seeing it now they were breaking me
down so that little kid that little
warrior Espinoza in there that the young
kid that wants to that is peeled off
right through the hurt through the fear
through the mistreatment all that is
pulled off I'm not ever going to be the
same as those other however you you you
become a success but that little boy
I want to get back there because that's
the whole and complete person that I was
so when I strip off all the
right without the socialization that
comes in through the society or the
socialization that happens in your own
family the pure thing you know your kids
fighting each other or brothers fighting
each other or in your neighborhood Bobby
Cervantes you know gonna pick on him
because he's black he looked like
cochison and he was the target of every
teacher we had
through racism and classism and
everything else how is he going to get
power to fight back
right how are you going to take somebody
that that is in a community if you were
just taking our family our community our
seal Community our family community we
all fought back
so that's why there were so many of us
and that's why we're all even though
later on in our lives we do things that
cause Discord between me and you as a
teammate
the bottom line the one thing that we
did have was that relationship of
understanding that we were being
revealed
not created but being revealed that yeah
well
in order for me to do this in order for
me to be my notes you don't have a Rolex
but the whole Seal Team real seals got
them no I just got a Time X
I'm not in the real seal category
anymore
yeah in Vietnam which and we pull the
covers off our road did you guys get
issued you guys that got issued though
tutor Rolexes yeah see that's you know
yeah I got some kind of I'm gonna file
that with the complaint department you
should you should I got jacked that's
how we knew who we were you know matter
of fact I'll tell you a story about this
thing but but you know that well I
always say that well when people ask
about you know buds which was buds for
me it was udtra for you
like they don't teach you anything and
they don't teach you mental toughness
you just the people that don't have it
go away right you sort it's sorting
itself out in you yeah and and uh and
and you know the beautiful thing about
it too is that when you're both doing
that and you and I are in the mud and
we're crying like this
and you look up and you I look at Garcia
and go
because okay all right in that book who
cried out right you know or pat on the
ass or hey we can do this you know
and and chief Allen and it said
especially on the race piece with that
about who I am as a human being right
the great spirit that I am the light
that's in me that that moves forward
right
me and Gregory Lee Garcia because we got
rolled to 41 right we're sitting there
looking at each other well man
we're we're screwed you know uh
yeah I know did you ever know Macintosh
yep
so McIntosh yeah so Butch comes walking
in now he's in my class he comes walking
in he goes hey you guys in a 42 go yeah
he goes oh so am I it says and I'm glad
I'm glad to see you guys man this is
because we're like why is that he says
well we've got to stick together
I said what do you mean we got to stick
together he says because we're
minorities
I said I said hey I said me and Garcia
we know women know what he said but
you're a white guy because he's he's his
complexion do you know Butch no it's
Megan oh that's right because he's from
like the islands St Thomasville yeah
so he sit there and he says no he says
uh I'm not a white guy I said yeah
you're white he goes no I'm on he says
I'm from Saint Thomas VI it's so Gregory
goes what's the vi this is the Virgin
Islands we're Fresno and Colorado I said
you mean there's virgins on the islands
the name of that no man he said it's
named after Red Beard or Blackbeard the
pirate he says the days of the Caribbean
he says rum rum and lobster and the
islands that's where I'm from my mom was
I said but you're still you're still
you're still a white guy no he says I'm
black from my mommy says and I'm Dutch
from my papa
I says but I said you're you're a white
guy he goes no I need to fix his foot
like this he Stomps it down he goes no
I'm so mad so I go I go I don't know man
I think he's a white guy he says no no
no so the very first day of training
Chief Allen
gets up there Espinoza Garcia front and
center right
the six of us right the other four we
tried to be shallow we tried to sit in
the silence we don't want to be
you don't want to profile yourself you
don't want you sometimes you our
profiled it's just the way it is right
understanding that it is that it exists
right so he yells at us front and center
who yachi found fireman Esperance
reporters or the chief
oh yeah chairman Garcia reporters are
the chief
yeah you guys he's looking at us he goes
I'm going to use the word n right
Espinosa you've seen he's big black and
beautiful he's like you right
he looked at him and goes you see any
ends around here
there's got to be a trick question
because that's what you do the whole
training is that think about it the
whole training is when an instructor has
an event with you there's something that
they want out of you they're guiding you
or they want to provoke you either anger
or whatever that stuff and this and I
always learned it's always better to cry
when you're in pain than than to be in
anger because the results of anger can
it's a hard deal right so I said no no
jibella I said I don't see any I don't
see any around here Garcia
I don't see any around here
he says well from now on for the rest of
this class when I want an end front and
center it says when I want an end you
two come front and center right you
understand that
so I'm going
oh well Chief uh and we just got done
with the swimming trunks on our boots
right
I said uh I think
I think Megan
so he goes
Macintosh he goes where's he at we're
all out there right we don't have Sun
towns yet we're out there and he goes I
said the guy well we're on the far left
he goes
far left good because yes Macintosh
front and center so Macintosh he doesn't
run out there like we do you know
regular military so Macintosh Lopes out
like a like a gazelle
jumps that'll open it comes out in front
of the chief
Airman McIntosh reporter door chief he
goes
Macintosh
are you an in
no she fell and I'm a soul
she fell and looks at him he goes Turn
Around
so he didn't about face looks at the
back of his turn sideways turned
sideways
turn sideways against each other side of
the other he looked at him he goes
yeah Macintosh he says I think you are
an n as a matter of fact you're the
ugliest than I've ever seen
in my life hit the bay and take these
other two ends with you man so so there
we were we would be in class we'd be in
class she fellas hey it would look all
you ends hit the bay we run hit the big
get wet and we come back you know
recover right we come back and sit in
class
so
that's what he gave us
you know he gave that to us to say it's
kind of like a letter that I wrote to a
girl that I thought I was breaking up
with you know about oh I love you and
somebody says
oh and she didn't come back to me right
but it's just they say oh oh she gave
you a beautiful gift
I don't know what kind of a beautiful
gift is this we still broke up no the
deal is you wrote how you can love
somebody
that's who you're looking for that's
what they did they gave us stuff and put
us in that pain so that we would reveal
ourselves
so we could say well
and then one day he comes out and he
says all you nonnans hit the bay well me
me I knew who I was right
me and Garcia were standing there and
all the white guys gone and the two
Koreans and two Turks man they're in the
water too they're in the water right so
so that happened a couple times a couple
Evolutions right and so finally Yankee
too comes up he's Korean guy who calls
it
yeah I don't understand I don't
understand in not in
Mr Chong we water I said
you from now on you and in
okay okay okay I understand and so then
the two Koreans stood the whole class
went in the water and Mark schallenberg
who looked like howdy Duty he's got
little blue eyes you know good teeth
that actually later on in Oliver and
broke his teeth
pushed on his head on a on a on a
swimming pool right and the water is
decanated Steve Allen comes up to him
goes Challenger
foreign
s hit the bay
who got you fella
I said all you nonsense hit the bay Sean
Burger stood up says Chief Ellen today I
am an n
you look at me goes
cool walks off so then the rest of the
class the rest of the class are going
what the hell is going on with this
stuff we told him hey tell him he says
hey I'm so then after that everybody
knew and the Koreans knew but we didn't
tell the two Turks so the two Turks are
in the way then we finally we told them
but you know and the very first day of
training like in 41 Olivera comes up
right
he comes walking up got his ball cap
you here scarred there little blue
slicker
caught off you know the instructor
shorts
the big diver socks with his uh shiny
Cochrane boots
he comes walking up
got an umbrella
up and we're all standing out
there and he looks at all of us walks
out cocky
looks at all of us says
as you can see on my Slicker it says Big
G little O Little D
there's only one big G big O big D and
that's a creative of the universe
and he's the creator of you and me
but God's not here but I am so for the
next 18 weeks when I tell you to run you
will run when I tell you the drop you
will drop when I tell you this I'll
tell you what color he didn't about face
popped up his umbrella and walked off
that was another one of those that's but
knows you know what the hell you doing
here right
so those two instructors are were Moyes
picture
you know and and you asked more about
when he when you know he's he's told a
couple hilarious stories about classes
he's probably like
um
he's probably about two before Me Maybe
39 Maybe 37.
so you know he's older guy you know I
think probably 37 something like that
but anyway he did his stuff and uh he
tells a cool story about being with
Oliveira
they lost one of the boat Crews somehow
because they were trying during hell
week so they went out in a vehicle
trying to track them down find where
they are and they ran they had buried
themselves under their boat in the sand
so boom they hit it if I lost control of
the vehicle and they come back around
and everybody's up and about you know
and he says it's so cool because Oliver
disco says yeah we catch you hiding like
that again he says and we're going to
run over you again you know
he said we didn't know where they were
at you know but there's a lot of there's
a lot of that stuff you know but yeah so
those those two instructors and so then
when
we graduated right we went through the
training you know and we were in
different boat Crews and I did and I
assume all six guys also just made it
and two of us went in Seal Team we were
drafted uh in the Seal team when when I
met you for the first time you were
telling me about
um
but one of the instructors saying to you
can you change the temperature of the
water that was all over what happened
with that tell us that one I'm freezing
my ass off right you're 120 pounds right
I grabbed the big guys it wasn't it
wasn't a homophobic thing at all man I
was you know they're putting off heat
man and I wanted something so I'm
sitting there crying
all over here come on
who y'all bear
this temperature of the ocean
the temperature yours is too toasty warm
all over and I'm crying I got tears
because and I'm glad I was wet because I
don't no man wants to see another man
cry so I'm crying he says uh
can you change the temperature of the
ocean
and I'm thinking well if I piss in my
wetsuit
a little bit but I'm not I'm not wearing
a wetsuit
so and I don't want to be a smart ass
right because I just don't want to be
all these guys I said oh yeah I told you
instructed this one I went through
training and I I I mean if they
wanted to hurt you they could hurt you
anytime they wanted to right that's the
power that's that's like Society there
are some people that are here that are
here how do you want to function in it
you can be in it and be in pain but
you're not you're not going to give it
up so
I'm there in pain and uh
I said no Oliver
he looked at me and says and it doesn't
matter what the event temperature the
water is does it that's for those
two days later I'm freezing again
kind of remind me when I was crying in
the when the little kids were going to
beat me up you know okay
this is uh
uh can you change the temperature what's
the temperature of the water Aspen it
doesn't matter what the temperature of
water is all over
he goes
Espinoza the temperature of the water is
toasty warm
so so then I understood right I can't
change the temperature of the ocean
right and the thing about the teams is
the only easy days yesterday right those
two things in my life were very powerful
same as that fire that hit me right but
that is that piece that I'm telling you
is being revealing
the one thing I did have though
was to say I can't change the
temperature of the ocean but I'm here
if I
or thought of being with my six guys
right
that not one of us gave it up
and that I can't give it up I gotta I'm
choosing to be here because anytime I
can leave anytime nobody's telling me to
stay here nobody's telling me to be
whatever all the hurt and fear I've
changed I'm changing I'm evolving and
that day it was like
three choices one I can quit
the second is
I can be here in misery
or I embrace it and say this is the cost
let's see what it costs
and in order for me to be where I want
to be there is going to be the point
where
and I think guys get it after they've
graduated and go into your downrange
into the combat area I'm going to die to
do this
I would rather die
then quit that is part of the cost
and that's what I love about my brothers
when I look at them and we come to all
that point right and we go out into our
world and we understand that and we
bring that into ourselves
and then
those cats that have all these bad
behaviors the racism the sexism the
heteros what all that all those
really weird behaviors
at one point in their life they were
clean and a child
they were for real
then after that they go back and they
pick this up bring it back because
that makes them feel comfortable of
where they were they don't want to live
in that that that Spirit of being free
of being who you are because it makes
you accountable to everything that
happens to you
good or bad psychological
when I got on the fire department I was
dead
I'd become inhuman I remember getting to
Vietnam and dad said give me
so I always remember you're a human
being
and I almost almost lost that and I
remember seeing a jar of yours right it
wasn't my platoon don't know who did it
or whatever but my officers being
leaders
came up and oh boasts and Campbell man
he was an enlisted guy who became an
Ensign retired actually as the
lieutenant commander I think
he says see this we're all like
what what is it you know and then we
says we don't do this
We're Not Gonna We're not gonna just get
rid of this get rid of this jar we don't
do this anybody we kill is gonna
have a weapon
or if they're collateral damage with
people that have weapons we're going to
do that but we're not going to do this
kind of stuff afterwards
I guess it was one of the things with
the pro program it was kind of weird
because they kept body counts like that
you know that inhumanity thing that
whole
CIA you know the whole proof
thing you know that they're all Cowboys
you could do whatever you wanted you
know and uh
you know I I think when I was there
a man's in humanity in a man you know I
was I was with my buddy noise right we
were working for the company and doing
stuff and we took a break
went to Saigon to party
hopped on a helicopter took off
I believe my cousin with the Poo program
it was crazy but
party with this I saw this I was always
practicing my skills my language skills
and I saw this little Vietnamese guy
looking at me I'm looking at him I said
hey lady
comes over Anthony what's your name
beer you know you drink beer yeah
he looks on me I said yeah yes I know
yeah me yeah
so it's just it's just friends came we
sat and we drank liked him you know we
connected you know you know sometimes
you don't even know somebody but you you
feel good with them right
we did that for two days third day we
had to leave and when we left because he
was trying to learn English I was trying
to learn English Vietnamese and hugged
each other catch you later and we take
off
noise was going oh I'm in this
Vietnamese they all know I'm an American
but we were in civilian clothes they
don't know who you are you know but so
bill was sitting like this you know
looking around but we spent three days
there
and when we took over this group which
was a green break which was the
pre-program my cousin was a Green Beret
and another guy
matter of fact when we flew in he was
flying out did the Green Berry had Sleek
wearing his Aviator Shades and stuff and
this guy is a is a black Sergeant
um
can't remember his name but he said oh
you just you just missed Captain Pacheco
and I'm like wow
and I said uh what's his first name and
he told me I said from Pacoima
California he goes yeah I said
that's my cousin ah I says his
mom's Aurora and his dad's celestino
yeah I said yeah he's my cousin so when
I got back country right
I started asthma says you ever heard
this I mentioned the name I mentioned
the caseworker I mentioned the sergeant
and and the name of the city and he goes
why are you asking me this
I said do you remember when you got
relieved and you hadn't saluted some
cats coming in
it's even close because yeah so it was
me and my mate you know then he
asked me he says what about there's a
guy with the white scarf
uh Vietcong
he said that do you ever run into him I
said yeah he shot the out of us you
know we were using the Army tactics we
weren't using seal tactics right and and
how we would Patrol and our warning
orders
they were
you know doing a fast uh warning order
then the brief op and then and going we
never left we never it was like right
away
it wasn't like uh
an hour going an hour later we we popped
out right away because we knew about
that the Intel leaks and so
we when we got back we decided to do a
quick op I said let's just go out work
so we grabbed like Five Guys we took off
didn't even tell the rest of the group
and we went out night early in the
morning we got hit we went and checked
the bodies
and as a kid with the white scarf
and a kid with a white scarf was a kid
that we drank with in Saigon
I look at him man and I got
you know I get emotional
and I still I told noises hey come here
man so Billy goes there and looks and he
goes oh man that's uh I think his name
was Tran but yeah
he looks at me and goes man
you know and that's when I understood
that Warriors right
that the ideologies of countries right
use us
that we go fight these wars we go do
whatever that is
but
um I wrote it my God I wrote it on my
phone
right now I'm kind of
well someone on the other side is doing
the same thing doing the same thing but
we're human you know there was that
there was that connection
that we as soldiers are fighting these
wars for other people's ideologies but
if they'd left us alone
we would have been best friends so when
I got on the fire department guys are
playing oh you got to remember where
you're from you know you you know all
this and I'm like did you ever
kill a commie for Mommy Mother you know
like
no you know didn't there's a whole thing
about how I
fit into the fire department
but
but I would tell them it says I've
killed I've killed a better man than you
and meaning it
because that guy and I
would have been friends we laughed we
drank we smoked cigarettes and uh and
when we left we we felt sad
that that it wasn't going to work and
then and then you meet a month
small world man
you know
and um
my heart broke that day
you know and I told this story to my
grandson and he he put it like in the
poem but he said
uh and his heart was crushed
and I was
I was that was that was hard you know
other than uh
and then getting connected there's a guy
named tick Vietnamese guy our
appointment
we got jacked up one time he said that's
me see I said let's go we go kill
communists
so let's go buzzed we went out we set up
on a we were set up on a river
waiting
nothing happened
to the world that could ever see but him
sitting beside me right
and thinking okay we're going to war
and if it happens we are together
didn't say a word but the connection the
spiritual connection the blending of us
as Warriors
you can't you can't buy that
you can't create it you can't form it it
it exists in the spiritual sense you
know
let's go back to
just to cover this part of your history
to when you graduated butts because you
mentioned it but you didn't go into too
much detail about that you were one of
the few guys that got selected to go
straight to Seal Team Seal Team One
without going to UDT at the time the
normal procedure was guys graduate buds
they go to UDT the underwater demolition
teams they do deployments there and then
they can volunteer to go over to Seal
Team which is going to be more
land-based Still Still foot in the water
but gonna be more land-based but you
went straight to
straight you got to order straight to
Seal Team one right why do you think
that was
well Captain schaible
um not actually called Captain Anderson
was the commander when we were selected
he actually lives in Ignacio New Mexico
no Colorado
and uh
well you get together he'd say
he says yes but knows he says I picked
you you and Jackowski and oh you meant
he knows all the names right
I said what was with that
he says we weren't getting we weren't
getting the guys that were volunteering
from UDT because we were getting shot up
I mean uh
and I think even Roger Hayden that's why
Roger I mean he he got shot up and stuff
in UDT he figured here and if he goes he
said I want to get my ass shot if you're
doing UDT I want to go into Seal Team
and figure this out I want to if
we're gonna if we're UDT guys you're
gonna be running seal Ops I want to know
what I need to know to do that
and so
the whole switch up in operations from
the water work to the land the guerrilla
warfare right
UDT all the water work explosives up to
the Berm line and then we're from the
hinter line in as far as we can go now
you guys so you're going in big old huge
helicopters taking them going hell no
man I'd rather be in the jungle you know
just and uh and they weren't getting
them
and so what he did is he he had the
instructors
start hand selecting guys that they
think could transition and then they
took the
they took the volunteers
they they took the volunteers at UDT
guys and it's really God you know the
way things work out guys like from 38
and 39
are marrying up with guys from 42
and 41s right so a lot of the guys in
those classes
like um
uh leg Crawford right he was part of the
dirty dozen right and his instructor was
um one of our structures was Barry Enoch
right and then some of the guys
that were with him too were out of class
3839 and the guys that I operated with
like Hyatt and Richards and D'Angelo
they're from 38 39 right
so this whole
group when you talk about only 150 guys
I mean they're making multiple truths
I'd have made two but I broke my leg in
a platoon workup right and uh and I
about cried I did cry because I was in
Balboa Hospital and felt like it felt
like that damn hell week when the guys
were going around in the paddle you know
and going to finish up hell week I'm not
going
I that's what I'm gonna do that's what I
want to do and there were no doubts and
I think I think if you had the doubt and
I don't know how guys work now if you
have any doubt you don't belong going
you know take off
I told you guys on the fire department
you don't want to do everything take off
the damn Maltese if you don't then all
we had was the little gold wings but I
remember chief chief Stone we're going
through SEAL training sealed CAD rate
right we're out there in nylon we lived
in boxcars
there was only two girls in the bar that
place was lunar face and crater face and
everybody was hot on them and they make
them feel like Queens you know well the
desert boys didn't like that so one day
like eight of the desert boys came down
and there was a
a tuxel in the bar right
I don't know where Chief Stone he's a
little guy like me he's a Korea guy he's
he is Korea guy but also
um a Raider wow army army you know the
Army Raider guys right Ranger whatever
you know because there were the Green
Beret guys but they were also the
Rangers
My Little Beard you know the guys are
all laughing and everything and he comes
in there
God
says you m effers and he's the guy he's
the guy when we're standing going with
training he goes yeah well damn well two
rows of corn here two rows of corn here
I don't want my M60 man over here my M16
here my Grenadier is over here my Stoner
Man and the officers with your M16s I
want you over you're assigned right he
said when that left foot hits you got
the M16 I want that that he says and if
you own M60 they want
so you Stoners I want some singing he
says in the officer every once up boom
and then you granted deer I want you
every fourth time your left foot yet I
want boom
you understand you're all like yeah we
understand it so he'd stand behind us
okay let's move you know we're like
we're like a we're like a rock and roll
man just
but really looking at the rate of fire
you know and the intensity of it right
so we were trained in in that small
group of what it felt like to be
powerful
powerful Invincible right and so they
would grab the guys from UDT they would
marry us up into this seal Cadbury class
and there's there's a book Vietnam SEALS
or whatever
in Vietnam and my cousin found the book
at Annapolis she went to Annapolis and
you can see up there it says SB and mo
the boat how they were signed and
they're doing the instruction that's how
basic it was you know
because you weren't getting guys to do
it
so he wanted and I think that was the
beginning of transitioning the UDT teams
I mean the kids that are going through
buds now and just saying well we can
save this time
because we when we went to jump School
of seals right
um the UDT guys had already gone through
jump School
but those of us who are in they went
through the seal Cadre that hadn't done
that trip weren't Airborne yet so we go
to jump School
and we were in shape man so we were out
there doing the run around we ran at
least three or four guys into the dirt
you know they sit there as they get your
10 chin ups and I do one for the Army
and I could do 50 of them at that time
because I was a little guy right one for
the Army one for the Navy one for the
Marines oh yeah smart ass give me a
couple more and I did I'd get all the
way up to about 47 45 and then I'd you
know instead of yelling huiad yellow
Airborne you know Airborne Sergeant you
know and they
they didn't know who we were that was
what the other thing was so cool about
being a team they didn't know who we
were we uh
matter of fact me and my partner uh
we're in
we went in we could we didn't talk to
anybody right didn't talk to any army
guys you know is that Airborne School
Airborne school yeah we didn't talk to
anybody and they assigned guys that put
us up into this Barracks where we were
at so where are you guys where you from
away just hey come on man did you guys
talk we need to talk to each one of us
everybody just don't say anything and
you know and then we turn our head and
we're like
you know just playing that whatever that
role is but nobody had to tell you
it just happened it was just like
everybody would pick up on the energy of
everybody else that's the other thing
that's created in in the training class
you can see him
there's a group of kids from Team eight
when I went to a golf tournament I could
see when they came in they're all
picking up on the energy of each other
all wearing shirts that they got from
Walmart and one has a cat one has a bird
one you know wearing their flip-flops I
mean that whole they're so out of
uniform that they're in uniforms does
that make sense yeah yeah you could tell
who a frog man is be just by the stuff
that he
doesn't wear to not conform but he is
conformed right
so you know it uh
but anyway back back to Chief Stone he
yelled at it says you sons of
are living on the reputation of dead men
get all the money you got out of your
pockets leave it for them and I'll meet
you back at the area and then we just
had a big old hole in Earth that we
threw wood into the not an island we
built a fire in and you sleep in these
box cars with these Springs and you put
your bed in there like a mummy thing and
we wake up in the morning there's a damn
snake in there with you you know and but
that night we operated all night long I
mean it was it was kind of like it
almost like a two day off all night The
All Night Thing with no sleep and you
were glad that you went through hell
week because you could operate like that
you could you could do that
and um
and and
he never scolded us after that
you know he told us some of the
are living on your reputation to dead
men made us hurt
and he says you're not seals yet
I understood it I'm not you're not seals
yet
so I finished seal Cadbury right those
of us who made it through and Garcia and
Macintosh hey I'll meet you at the
Tradewinds Tradewind bar that's where we
all hang out right I said all right
so we we show up we show up there and
and the night before I'm gonna meet him
next to the night before
I'm sitting there in a Happy Meal beer
and this lady comes up
sits beside me and she sits right beside
me and I'm like
you're one of those fngs
I'm like
I don't know I said now he says FNG it's
I don't know what that is
new guy
I'm like well yeah I guess I guess I
got my Rolex right I got my real links
yeah I'm almost a new guy I got my Rolex
um
well I'm chief gustavo's wife someone
tell you something
I can out drink you
I can now fight you and I can out f you
20 years old I'm sneaking into the bar
right
and uh so
she says FNA right right so I you know
you can have mine I just got it but
anyway she says I'm gonna tell you
something
this is the chief has three tours of
Vietnam
it's never been hurt
never got anybody killed
he says we lost a couple guys and I
think by the time Funk had gotten all
the guys had gotten killed were on
stupid like Funk they had him hand
tied and they were going to show these
Senators how we do stuff when we capture
people the boat broached he went into
the into the river found him four or
five days later and the way the water
runs is so dark and and the current
killed him right we we kill our own
for stupid or guys drooling on a
two millimeter mortar and it kills guys
Mike Corman who went to Vietnam with
this he switched out with a guy that was
a regular corpsman that was with Marines
he switched out with him so he could
this other guy could get his
pay right
and Doc mainers walking with another guy
that goes off they're walking by and
kills both of them
a guy named Van Hoy who had like well he
wrote everybody man he had his
together right doc Maynard uh
um
that's how you lose guys right
but um
um so what did she tell you so she told
me you said yeah thank you uh
so you don't get him killed
and if you don't want to do this job if
you don't know what you're going to go
and this is from my wife right
and sometimes I guess my understanding
is some of the wives take on the
personality of the officers wives start
their little stuff you know met my
daughter is
is the wife of an officer Marine Corps
officer and
but she let me know the human piece
right this is a family I mean she they
have there's their family and this is
what it means to her and I'm responsible
for myself to make sure he doesn't get
killed and I have to learn that stuff
not just for me and I understood that
that
sometimes in the teams well I don't want
to let anybody down right
it isn't that at all
if I could do anything like that and
then you let yourself down and I have I
mean I'm not sinless you know but I know
that when I when I come to that point
where I do something I don't want to do
and don't do the things that I should do
the greatest disappointment is me
because I I don't have power over that
or I chose
to do whatever I did
and so I looked at her and I went
no ma'am I said if I if I I don't know
where I'm going I mean I just graduated
sealed training I don't know where I'm
going I said I I promise and chief
custom was a cool dude you know he was a
good operator and everything so I got
that so next day I told Macintosh Garcia
said I want to meet you you know all
right you know as we get together
and it was early in the day and you you
never there was a Tradewind bar when you
went was it an IB no it was it was right
this is where the little
um it's on Orange Avenue down from mcps
between Danny and mcpeases where the ice
cream place is yeah no it was gone but
anyway it had Swinging Doors you walk in
there you walk in and
a lot of a lot of character and a lot of
who we were is the
um not just the operational piece but
the interpersonal piece right
um so we walk into this place ring
indoors and we look down and there's
this guy
got cha in his mouth and smoking cigar
it's by the bathroom and you weren't
sure whether he was the bathroom had a
problem with plumbing or there was him
he's eating boiled eggs and drinking
beer and he went to the head he was like
and he had a full growth
and I'll just
the guys and those guys on the team will
know that it was tobacco right because
he had a lot of tobacco right
so he looks down at us and me Macintosh
and Garcia
so says hey you guys the fngs
I already knew who it was already told
me who I was we go yeah
I think he says that's all we need in
the teams is more effing ends
Mexicans and ends
so I was like
hooyah you know
so we just looked at each other the cool
piece about it we already knew who we
were Chief Fallon already established it
for us Oliver had already established it
for us I don't know who this cat is
but he's an operator and he has every
right to say whatever he wants to say to
me because I not done anything right so
I missed my first platoon I go over and
do my trip do my Vietnam thing
well what happened on your you broke
your leg
in your first work up oh you're shooting
or what were you doing tell everybody
yeah I was parachuting man uh repelling
was one of the other things when I got
to Balboa Hospital it was like how'd you
do that
oh
I'm sure I was repelling how far away
from deployment were you
two weeks oh
getting ready to go on deployment what
happened so what we did what we were
doing was doing um a Compass Course
right Alpha Brown you had these
different legs and we went by ourselves
like about four minutes behind each
other so we we'd cover each other right
not
we didn't go in pairs we went singles
and so I'm this is like a 10 mile deal
right so I'm up on this rock and I'm
looking thinking oh I got another
I don't know maybe a mile to go down to
this other Rock
I have my black face on have all my
stuff I got my weapon in this hand I got
my compasses and everything and I'm
looking and here comes the guy on a
horse
I said hey he says how you doing this is
good how you doing this is don't find
someone does a nice ride today I said oh
lie cheats still do whatever you can to
get through but don't get caught right I
said if you don't happen to be going by
that rock down there
he says I'm going right by that rock I
said how about a ride so sure so I get
ready to shift my you know my hands over
to a weapon to reach up to you at me he
goes oh no he says you're a little
enough he says I'll just pull you up
I said all right so put my foot put my
that's the other thing you learned is
don't let anybody else have control over
your right you just don't don't do
it you got to do your own stuff so he
reaches down grabs hold me slings me up
next thing he falls
sideways so here let's loosen my hands
so I take my hand and I grab up like
this and I grab hold of the saddle I
have my weapon here and I stick on this
side that horse takes off oh next thing
I'm running next thing is like oh this
thing in my leg I look at my feet
they're both above my heads I have my
maps here and have my weapon here and
when I hit it was like
and I went oh so he scampers off
then he comes back you okay
I said no man I don't think I am
she gets off his horse and he said well
let me and he got his little bag and he
cuts my laces off and looks at my leg
and then I took my little 38 I had you
know
hand weapon
doc Maynard was by Carmen right he's
when you swapped out he's the guy who
got killed Dr Maynard comes down
and by that time another guy comes by on
a horse
and he says what's going on he says I
think this guy's got a fraction well
Alias you know looks like a disulfibular
break he's got Beetle pulse and I didn't
know what any of that stuff was I'm I'm
just a soldier man and uh
so
I said so what's going how do you guys
know this stuff it's oh we're doctors
we're up here on a little
I said ah so they splinted and
everything by the time doc doc got there
that was already squared away he says
you have any drugs
said no we don't have any drugs because
he would give morphine but then with the
morphine shred he always had to do the
dog he didn't want to do that
and so the duck said well here it gives
me a pint of peach Brandy let's just
drink this
got in a little jeep that he did that
the dog get me this kind of
kept track of us by the time I got to
Balboa man I was jacked up you know so
they had to wait give me a block and so
then my platoon came because I was in
the hospital and they all give me a kiss
goodbye man and I was and this guy
um Alan took my my job
and I hated him
I was so envious and so hurt and so
pissed off that he's got my job with my
platoon and in the opportunity with
mihach mihach and I were the point man
in that platoon right
and I wanted I wanted to go work so that
means I had to stand down again and all
these guys that I was with
right
so then I had to do it took me two
months right so I'm in Balboa Hospital I
got my foot up like this
his Seal Team on it once they found out
who I was the guys from Cason were
coming in they were shot jacked up man
I'm sitting there watching them come in
and
they put this guy beside me and
still a machine is going in and got I
mean people were jacked up I saw war
from that I saw the the the the damage
this machine goes off stops a little
light so I push the button
started back up again
so it happened about four times it was
like in the middle of the night I pushed
this button
by myself my team's gone
and uh
pull the cord for the karma and he
doesn't show up finding when he does
show up I said so what do you need so
what's this
who went off why'd you do when did this
happen I said I've been for four hours
right so he grabs and takes off
then he comes back this guy comes back
about two days later he's a Marine he's
got a patch on his eyes leg is jacked up
and he's got wounds in here
he looked at me and says uh
you're the guy who's pushing the button
oh yeah
yeah
he said I was drowning
is this when when the button would go
off he says I would start drowning he
said you push the button and sucked that
stuff out of my lungs
so he and I became good friends and I
was only there for another
I went back and checked him out later on
he had like a floppy leg and his eyes
missing and when I went back and saw him
he says I said how you doing he said I'm
doing great man this is someone they're
going to send me to MCRD I said really
Marine Corps Recruiting Station right
he's going to receive troopsies yeah he
says and check this out Espy he's at his
patch on his eye he goes like this
Marine Corps emblem inside his eye he
says I'll be receiving those guys he
says look me in the eye boy you know
so he was a cool guy so yeah I miss I
miss my platoon and and so then when I'm
there I have Seal Team went on there and
this guy comes walking in got his Rolex
got his ball cap
and I look his Cocker and jump boots and
and I'm going oh it's a team guy so
I said hey man I was at the gee dunk
with the CB and this is at the hospital
at the hospital I said look at this guy
and I say hey man this is you in the
teams
because yeah
I said so am I he goes
so what the and walks out
so I'm like are you rude son of a
you know I mean you know I mean man
pissed off so I bet did about another
month there and then I I left right went
back to the Seal team area it's okay yes
but you're back here uh Locker 69. go
take it and change it put your new gear
and stuff that's all right
so I go over there and I look at the
lockers they're like they were like this
you know like these spaces here and
there was a window at the end and mine
was at the end
so I go over there and I look there's
when I go in I walk by the lockers
there's that guy that told me so what
the
so I walked by him he just kind of looks
at me I don't know if you wrecked you
know it just kind of looked at me I kind
of looked at him and I went there's a
name up there so I grabbed it pulled it
off and I threw it in the can
and he goes that was a good man
I was just so what the
he looked at me man and it was like
we're gonna ride we're gonna dance you
know we're gonna dance and I backed up
into the corner and he just looked at me
and he goes
you
turns around walks out and I went
wow that was pretty intense you know
and so then we we go out and they say
okay we're going to start signing up the
tunes off alpha bravo charlie Echo
platoon right so they started naming
names Echo platoon Espinoza oh shoot man
that's cool so it goes on and then uh
they call that guy's name
he comes walking to my platoon I'm going
oh and you guys are both an echo platoon
both of us in Echo platoon and I pulled
that name tagum Threw It Off
that later on I found out that he was
with a guy named Anton that had gotten
killed in a fire fight the Maguire
rigged him out he got hit two times
I
they were they went on two helicopters
to an op and
they dropped everybody off so they were
patrolling
they took Antone and moved him up
forward
and never really was never was really a
point man right but they hadn't moved
him up out of
out of his out of what he normally does
he stepped out and in the jungle there's
a lot of times you you just step out and
it's a base camp right and uh and if
you're not really quiet they know you're
coming
and so he stepped out they got engaged
he got shot killed the two Vietnamese
another American and two guys wounded
when I talked to my my partner and and I
learned about this so that was what the
op was right
so I didn't know
that that Anton had gotten killed and
then I understood what had happened we
were in sampling tomb for
three months and didn't talk to each
other
I didn't talk to him he didn't talk to
me we look we'd work and do stuff and
there was like the visual connection
about what we're doing
but it was like
um
hard
it was hard I'm not gonna
there was like
I don't know
like two invisible forces that had no
way to communicate was like a big wall
you know
and then one day I'm walking to the
trade winds to go to the trade with have
a beer and he pulls by in his car reason
he was in there because he gotten drunk
and broke out his teeth that's why he
was there
and the only words he ever said Espy
yeah he says uh
where you going
that's what I'm going to Tradewind
you want to ride
I hate walking man I said yeah so I get
in there didn't say a word we drove up
to the bar right
park right in front we get in there's
nobody in there right
well except for tobacco Lewis nobody
tobacco right that guy I'll tell you
about I'm kind of digressing but in the
same place with me McIntosh and Garcia
came in there and when he said all we
need is team some more ends and right so
I told you about that right yeah so so
that was tobacco Lewis yeah okay we
ratted him off that was that goddamn
tobacco Lewis and so so we come in and
and and and I could and he's still
sitting down there right so we walk in
he just kind of looks at us and Hyatt
says uh you know beer I said yeah and
there and there was a k again in the
trade it was as high at the name of the
guy that you had not been able to
communicate with yeah I love him
and now he says hey you want a beer he's
my best friend yeah in the teams yeah I
shouldn't ratted him off but he's he's
okay
so
he says you want a beer and he said yeah
so he pours a beer
pitcher and guys would buy kegs of beer
for getting divorced getting married
uh getting promoted getting demoted
getting killed in Vietnam coming back
from anything there's always there's
always a keg in there Monday yeah Monday
Wednesday
yeah so there was always one there so
there was always a cake so like about
three o'clock to probably about five I
mean guys I'll get there and drink a
bunch of beer and then it would go on
so we drank that Kate that that that
picture of beer and then he said uh now
he said hey you want another picture he
goes yeah sure so I poured him a beer we
sat there
sitting in the corner I'm sitting right
here he's right here the door is right
there you always I always sat there
because you know you know you don't ever
walk in that door either without kind of
check because you could get hit pretty
easy I mean there's some good fights in
there it was a wild place and um
you want to hear about Antone
I said yeah so he told me about the
helicopters about getting hit and
getting out and saying man I don't know
how we flew out of there you know I mean
everybody was wounded the helicopter was
shot everything was he said and he
didn't get hit he's never been hit right
uh
I was with him
uh anyway he was sharing that story with
me you know and then he's crying
and I'm crying
and guys it was so beautiful about the
bar was man the other guys would come in
they go
uh they got a thing going on not not to
interrupt you and not look down on you
guys are having their own memorial times
for themselves in your own space in your
own and respecting it you know
that that was it was kind of like the
womb I mean that bar was kind of like
for guys who come in with pain they
would come in with anger they would come
in proud that they have kids you know
that it was it was a place that
that everybody felt safe you know
and uh
so he that's when he became my teammate
you know of him sharing that with me you
know and
we did a talk one time for Sea Wolf
gunships you know he'd come to Texas and
he says
Espeon tell me that story about the Sea
Wolf gunships and
I go what do you tell he goes oh no you
said you like you like talking you see
you tell
so I said all right so we got shot at
you know for we were on a dike and these
guys shot at us
so we're and and Hyatt had his
together the officer we had was a young
guy right so he's like do we engage him
you know and
and I when you look out there he goes
that see that being engaged
me shooting engage here the the guys
that were shooting at us on this little
kind of an up like a little dike you
know we were up on top of it actually
they were shooting up at us well the
first thing is somebody's shooting at
you down from down below
they got something you know but but he
was a brand new officer actually he he
relieved both in Campbell who'd stepped
on a booby trap
that was that was another op that we
were on lit him up appointment got some
shrapnel in his ass and Doc mainers was
with us and he had me walk the point out
and uh but I'm kind of getting a little
Crossways here but
um
where was I at so I mean just basically
you were talking about the trade winds
and how that's kind of when you guys got
tight and I mean I suppose the next
thing is so you're doing a work up and
preparing to go back to Vietnam or
preparing to go your first deployment to
Vietnam right right and and was that was
that like a six month cycle you go to an
island it was a six-month cycle you go
to an island nylon you go quiamake do
the jump thing you do you have just
mostly you know patrolling how many guys
you got in your platoon is there 14 yeah
14 guys
and uh and he told me he says yes but he
says you stay with me you won't get hurt
it's all right miss my see Daddy man
he's my partner this is Hyatt yeah
and so uh matter of fact I have this
watch because of him
we come back from Vietnam
we go under he says how much money you
got
I don't know so count your money out
so I got the 125 bucks he says grabs at
the same man I said give me my money he
said we're going out and partying
tonight nope you're coming with me so we
go to the PX
I saw there's nothing in the PX I want
says yeah so we go in there and he looks
at the lady says I want that one and
that one see two relics and she puts
them up
I said lady it says I don't want to
Rolex
so she puts it down
it's the lady says he wants a Rolex so
she puts it up I said lady I don't want
to relax so she puts it down
so finally he says lady
puts it up I said lady and she goes
little fella he's a lot bigger than you
and today you remind yourself an Rolex
watch you know it was that kind of a
thing and we went we took a break one
time went to nabeas where he got
operated he had this was his third trip
too with Seal Team and one with UDT and
uh
they threw us out they threw us out of
the base for fighting and so we had
nowhere to stay except for
places that he knew you know like out in
town yeah out in town
yeah yeah so we were out in town hiding
we were out there hiding right and so at
night you know during the day we'd kind
of hang out and then at night the Viet
Congo would come in so we'd be sheltered
in these places and if you had Cong
would be in these places that we were at
during the day partying and drinking and
dating girls and or whatever
and and we were we were hiding and then
in the morning the Viet Congo would
leave and then we'd wake up you know for
three days we did that
that close to the enemy is cool you know
they don't even know that you're there
you know
and uh so that was our that was our
relationship so when you're uh you
finish your work up
and now it's time to now it's time to
fly to Vietnam now it's time to fly did
you leave from North Island we left from
North Island well like a c130. see one
yeah the little one little c117 oh dang
okay cargo plane right so that's that's
what we win we staged all our gear into
everything we get in there and
um what year was this 69
this is March March
Yeah March of 69 March of 69. so we
we're getting ready to roll looking at
the rivets and stuff looking at the
chief that comes in there to fly the
airplanes
big old belly got his Chiefs hat and
he's the pilot he's the pilot oh that's
pretty cool and you look out the window
and look the
airplane has all this grease and oil and
stuff we'll go flying like this next
thing is like
it was like what the hell you know we
turn off and
and so we get ourselves back together
goes what's happening he says oh I was
looking at the lights
says look at the green light and the red
light the green light and the red light
pretty soon I said well the green light
and the red light they're on the wrong
sides
he wasn't following he's coming right at
him right so he turns off so I'm going
oh man I don't even get the Vietnam
that's happening so then we get to
Hawaii right
so we go in and hide height says uh he
has to be I said let's uh let's have a
mai tai drinking contest is it cool all
right
we go in man
next thing you know I'm waking up I look
down and there's a tomato stuck on
Hyatt's face
whereas on the upper rack and I'd thrown
up it was on his face
posting Campbell you sounds so I
told you we're kind of looking around
and how it gets up his hair sticking up
in the air you know and I'm looking at
him
so I told you guys we're leaving at zero
six hundred you guys are late the
chopped I mean the airplanes rolling up
and you know now they says and the rest
of the goddamn platoon never told you
guys God get your asses and we're like
grabbing stuff you know I'm like
grabbing my boots putting stuff on it
and I asked both like I said hey bosses
who won the Mai Tai drink he got who won
the might I drink cause he a son of a
he says you guys got drunk and
then you got in a fight in the bar they
threw you out and then you guys stole a
damn
busy you know that they're driving
around and we threw the sailors off the
bus stole the bus and then they the
short Patrol tracked us down and we got
in a fight with those guys on the bus
then they arrested One Night in Hawaii
right there it was one night that's one
night
they need to get you guys to Vietnam oh
yeah we were and there's another platoon
that was before us uh I think is
I can't remember who's platoon I don't
think it was crawdads but anyway their
officer was in Vietnam waiting for him
well they got in the same fight but it
was the whole bar in that fight and and
I went to Barbara's point to see that
bar it's now a there's now a gym
but they got there and they got in a
fighting officer sitting over there back
in Vietnam waiting for his guy to show
up and where the hell they had and he
gets this communique that comes and says
we don't know who they are we don't know
where they came from
but we know they're headed your way and
those guys have gotten a fight and they
started a fire in the bar and the whole
I mean and if you think about it right
think about somebody that's going to go
to war
you're internalizing that and so
you are loose you know it's like and and
so you want to try to take these people
and tell them that no you you it's it's
follow the rules it's a hard one you can
try yeah that that is uh something that
in in the military for certainly in SEAL
Teams you know you like you're
parachuting you're diving they're doing
a bunch of dangerous stuff and when
you're young you're like well you know I
could die tomorrow so I'm gonna have a
good time tonight that's what we're
doing and the consequences right the
consequences of mistake are brutal
they're not you can if you're working on
an obvious finger whatever but we we
up up there we mess up out there
um and the same thing when it came on
the fire department you know two guys
got killed in my my fire training and I
thought okay Vietnam probably gonna get
killed got on the fire department maybe
but this is really a kind of a lame kind
of job man you fight some fire you do
some
I saw totally different when I got there
right it transitioned it changed for me
about especially when I went up in rank
it's like being a platoon leader you
know the other guys do whatever they
want to do in the platoon but as a
platoon officer and the platoon leader
then as a battalion chief when I was in
the fire department I'm responsible for
them
to keep them alive I become chief
gospel's wife
you know and uh and so
um
yeah it was
you really transition a lot about about
what that what that means and those
consequences and what's and what's real
and what is it to be a real frog man
right they're the machismo crazy cats
out there
but they um
are they good operators are they running
on on their ego or are they running on
the teams
you know do you love the teams or do you
love yourself
right and a lot of these cats and love
themselves wound up in trouble they're
willing to make that or create that for
for some reason
I look at some of the events you know of
how guys are getting killed now and
we're thinking
it's like when high when we got when we
got shot at and then the officer says we
take him under Fire
we look at him and go are you
crazy
if we we take them under Fire they're
gonna know how many of us there are
right so then we start receiving fire so
we cause an extraction
there was nobody coming to get us the
Army's sometimes the Army's slick guys
would not come in but a sea wolf they're
coming well they're coming man you know
and I've had quite a few Sea Wolf pilots
on here yeah it's freaking awesome and
so when they Lock and Load and they're
and they're dumping their ammunition
just to get four cats up I mean that
that whole that whole thing is on fire
right so we're running
so we had no air support until those Sea
Wolf guys said well we're coming
and uh
a couple Air Force guys yeah we're in
our little Phantoms and if you need some
help we can uh we can help you and so
I'm at the back end right everybody's
running blow everything up on the back
side of the blue blue strobe right so I
got a blue strobe lit up and I'm running
I got I got M60 I'm running heavy
running an M60 and I hide something
ahead of me and Richards he married his
sis his richer sister hi Mary Richard's
sister
and we all we're all we're good mates
man being
uh there's some bars in San Diego that
remember us just we're still still not
allowed in oh just by being crazy yeah
so I'm running and I fall in a hole I
mean and these guys Air Force guys are
coming flying like this right and when
they're lighting their stuff up it looks
uh it looks like it's sort of like about
10 15 feet up in the air because you're
running
but they don't tell you like you see the
movies I mean they don't then you're
getting support they don't talk about
the in those days the links are rolling
out
so you're running along
all the cases and stuffing is beating
the hell out of you and you're running
it like this you know try not to get
them down your shirt and you're running
and they're flying it's like two of them
in the water and I mean the casings and
I fell in this hole and it wasn't even
that they could hear me because the
whole world behind me I could feel the
heat and everything behind me blowing up
they just stopped
they ran back one grabbed the barrel the
other one grabbed the butt lifted me out
of the hole they took off running and
I'm like your feet aren't on the ground
every once in a while one would hit and
then finally I got my feet you know and
then we got over to the on
to see what was locked loading dumping
all the ammunition on the other side the
side that we were coming on they weren't
right and so we jumped in and then they
they started dumping it all and then
that Holograms you're trying to and
everything everything's going
well I told that story and then when
when I told me to tell it with the
Seawolf guys right he's in Texas
and so then
he says you tell the story I said all
right so then I feel okay I'll tell the
story in there as close as I could get
it because everybody has their own story
and uh
then I saw how I get up and he walked
over
up to the podium you know when I was I
was there and he comes up beside me he
says well that opted
as we just told you about he says I
didn't realize
how much
that helicopter meant to me and how safe
I felt once in my hand touched that
helicopter then I knew I was okay
and I never
I never ever thought that because he was
always so calm because when we all
opportune we were a bunch of calm people
you know and and that and when you have
that in your platoon
uh except when you're yelling and
they're running away from you I'm gonna
goddamn hole you know like you know uh
everybody is like that it's that
calmness that keeps you right and and if
your officers call me even boasts a
cowboy when he got lit up you know he
really did a real easy transfer to Doc
Maynard and they they an Air Force
helicopter with doctors happen to be
coming in we were in a booby trapped
area so we're trying to secure the area
and we're receiving fire from a little
Hooch down there and me and hayat lit
that that up there's that whole thing
the whole dynamics of like when I wrote
that piece about the flash right
the flash of War you know that whether
you're creating it or whether it's being
created for you
the
the inside Warriors working and figuring
it out the outside Warrior is
non-forgiving and violent right and
they're both standing out and and I
think you know the ins the little boy in
there is is watching that happen
and and I think the whole War piece is
totally alien
because that's not where we really want
to go so those of us that pay that price
you know it's going to cost you
something even in the training because
pain is going to cost you something when
I got back from Vietnam doing my out in
the world
I thought that was me that's just the
way that I am you know I'm fighting off
and all that kind of that's who Espinoza
is here's all my behaviors I I confused
my behaviors for who I
who I am and I let loose of it because
then I was alone again I lost all my
teammates I was in my platoon when I
lost them that time when I came from
Vietnam and I left right I'm alone again
right and it's taking me now
to come back to that space of
understanding my life
right
that's crazy I'm 75 years old trying to
figure this stuff out and then I look at
guys like you you got your podcast you
got your thing going Jujitsu if they'd
had MMA when I was coming back from
might have been
I was going I was going to Five Points
in Denver to fight mostly black guys
because that's where the danger was they
had guns and knives
and that was you're going to fight in
Boulder right with the hippies I mean
there's this
maybe there wasn't much
too much but so you might go to I might
go to my might go to this place called
uh Peggy's Hilo and you get a hook up
with a cowboy you know at least when
you're fighting those guys it was in the
dirt
you know but
and I remember going in there and this
one Big Brother's in there he goes I'm
looking because I'm checking security
right the other thing is looking at the
environment those challenges right I'm
looking at the bar where's the security
at where's these guys who who am I
watching out for it was like being
working with the crew program and
knowing that you had another 50 guys you
got there's probably eight or nine of
them that are Vietcong that are that are
two hois or they're they're they're
working both sides that was exciting
that was the cool thing about when I was
with my partner and I
work in that program versus work in the
Vietnamese seals Vietnamese seals we
knew and I did that with two East Coast
guys first
so I worked with them and then they took
another West Coast guy in my platoon to
work with those guys with the Vietnamese
seals and then they said oh by the way
you guys have that expertise why don't
you and me and me and Bill we went and
worked for the crews
we did that that's where I relieved my
cousin right
that whole thing that whole challenging
thing about depending upon
the the spirit and the understanding the
awareness about who you are
is exciting you know and I wasn't
getting that you know so I was creating
the tension
outside Warrior creates the tension so
that and that's who you think you are
and it's and so then you live your life
out like that you know you're a frog man
my mama I'm a genuine don't we say
genuine Barrel chested anti-magnetic
Chrome plated Rolex wearing keyboard
Karen rooting tune parachuting evidence
from frog man who can
to take 40 men 40 days to track me down
I can see in the dark breathe underwater
and I can fly you know that whole that
whole thing you know and uh
so it's uh
so that's that's who I thought I was
when I got on the fire department I'm
coming I look at all these
these guys don't even train you know and
then two guys get killed in training
then they're blaming everybody oh you
know you got this and this and that and
then none of you guys wanted to train
this is our fault
so then when my buddy got killed it's
kind of like what do I do here
the word sacrificial responsibility
comes up
sacrificial responsibility right Christ
Jesus man he didn't have to die him he's
God and everything else but he's going
gone should I Gotta Die for these morons
because they ain't going to figure it
out
right and so here you are
I'm going to Vietnam I'm going with
these guys why
that's not what your country could do
for you but what you can do for your
country so you go okay
um yeah
where can I go
my coach told me about being a frog man
right
then you get there and you see these
guys and you see these instructors
bigger than life
and nobody knew who seal was
I knew where Frogman was I wanted to put
them up Vermont wear my swim trunks and
get a suntan and all that stuff then
there's the choice I'm going to choose
to do that or not are you going to
choose to be part of this family or not
and there are kids in their own families
right now that are choosing they don't
want to contribute to but that about the
reputation of your family
my dad told me one time man I said Gibby
said the only thing that I ever gave you
was my last name don't be Dishonored on
it right
and this this same guy in fourth grade
education right
the biggest thing that I learned from
him was part of preparing me for the
teams
we were hunting
and my dad said Gibby we shot a note we
tracked him down it's getting cold it's
night I'm freezing we're poor we may
have cotton gloves there isn't any of
this Cabela's and all that right
I'm wearing two pair of two pair of
Levi's it's cold I'm 10 years old with
my dad
well we shot him we got to find him
we're Indians we don't leave we don't
leave stuff out here we'll track him
we'll make we'll find him I didn't
realize because of our subsistence we we
killed enough hunting in the winter time
and we fished all summer long that's how
we ate and we would plant stuff in the
garden and we'd raise chickens and
rabbits that's how we ate that's not a
bad diet but hell man you get tired of
getting eggs you get chickens
and skin and rabbits and and he asked me
if they're hunting right I'm going oh
Dad come on you know it says Nope so we
track him down there he is there he is
there's the oak so
we're tracking you can see a little bit
of the blood the wind's blowing it's
getting cold and everything else
sometimes I was fishing with him at
night I didn't want to be out there
freezing my butt off man and when I
would get cold out in Coronado man I
remember being a barker down freezing my
ass off with my dad
but I never thought about what the
temperature of the water was but I knew
I was cold so so I'm um
we we find the Oak and he says okay
Gibby says
now you got to go back and get the
hunters get the rest of the guys Mr Mr
Chavez my brother and Mr Gomez you know
is gone
Dad yeah Dad I said I don't know you
know he says look he grabs me looks at
me right in the eyes he says listen
what you're feeling is fear
I understand it
don't be afraid
I'm like
okay
so I take off you know and I went and it
isn't like left and right so then when
you're talking about the the spirit of
God right this this whatever it is that
guide you and when you're in combat
whenever you're doing stuff a lot of
guys a lot of guys have this a lot of
times they think it's them but then
there's other things just put you in a
different place and the only thing that
that you survived and other guys didn't
is time and chance
right and making a decision one way or
the other the thing however it gets you
there whatever it is and you can't feel
sorry that you survived and they didn't
that's life right so my dad sends me to
go find these guys I'm going I'm looking
at the track and there was like I don't
know where to go
and then in here it's like
I'm gonna go and I find it I find hey my
dad shot an elk and I grab him and they
come oh yeah okay and they follow me on
they grab their guns they grab poles
they we go out there and we find my dad
and he's out there
smoking cigarette
looking at him
Seth you know they're all Ah that's a
big elk you know and my dad had me we
always carried a little bag that had a
hatchet bone saw and his knives in there
right that's what he gave me before he
told me go get the hunters right
so I went up to where my dad was
and he grabbed my face like this
you know looking down at me
she says I knew you could do that
you know and when and when I when I read
like in the in the
that where God when when Christ got
baptized right the the word says that uh
so this is my son
who I'm well pleased
I thought it was my dad grabbed my face
and and told me that I thought wow man
it was my responsibility
but my dad's a surprise sacrificing my
life for a deer to go get those guys you
know but but you don't understand what
I'm saying it's it's like
uh
yeah and people say well it's a calling
to be a frog man well it's a it's
there's a thing I think our egos that
say well can I make it can I not some
guys can say I never had any doubt right
that they've been supported with their
families all the time right
my family supported when you're writing
a letter when I was rolling back into 42
about mom I really want I want this more
than anything in the world right and my
mom knew now
50 years later right they did that class
on 2 30. my mom said I knew you were in
Seal Team but I didn't know that's I
didn't know that's what you were doing
right after that's even after Vietnam
right I didn't know that that's what you
were doing but I do remember my mom
actually my sister said oh okay he said
yeah Mom almost got in a fight with Miss
Martinez what really says yeah she said
she told me you're going to Vietnam and
she said well all he is he's going to do
is be fodder
you told me my son's father and I'll
kick the hell out of you you know that
not always supported my mom was kind of
domineering and kind of mean really but
but uh
but I knew they were always there for me
you know and even when I came back and
Vietnam my dad
you know after my work up after I did
all my stuff
Vietnam veterans against War the young
socialist republic I'm going to school
at CU I got a letter when I was getting
back from Vietnam to wrestle at the
University of Colorado
a dream I thought was already gone I was
obviously 118 pounds
right so I barely make it 100 I didn't
really have to cut I was still just a
little guy these guys my kids we go to
reunions they sit there and look and
they finally got to the age where they
went Dad yeah he says
you're the littlest guy here
I've been the little guy of my life but
you know when when I got that letter
it's like
a whole new thing
I didn't fit I wasn't
Brown enough to be brown I wasn't white
enough to be fight I was a Vietnam vet I
just got done killing and call me for
mommy with my teammates and stuff like
that and they're telling me Viva La Raza
at salon and all that is like
I'm an American
you know my people have always been from
here and and it doesn't even have to be
that they're from here but this is what
I feel in here it's from my my heart
for my soul it didn't come but it did
the ego was yeah I could be it might be
one of those frog man until you start
getting shot at and then you're asking
yourself and going what the why am
I what am I doing here and then you come
out with all your teammates and
everybody you know like after the op
right you all sit there look at the
children and go
wow wow that was that was pretty intense
you know you guys yeah he's like and the
guy that was always
pretty cool was Lou you know when I got
when I got hit you know he was pissed at
me you where'd you get
where'd you get hit I picked up some
shrapment by Cambodia you know we would
we'd be on these barges and they'd float
down river and we'd operate off them and
uh this is when you got there that was
the first thing you got tasked with what
was the first thing you got tasked with
when you got on the ground what was your
job what did your platoon all operate as
a platoon or Jude immediately get shaved
off and uh no no first of all like for
the first three months you know we were
all operating it was all platoon
operations down in sedek off of pbr's
right what were you guys doing uh what
are you guys doing ambushes raids
ambushes prisoner snatch we'd we'd like
find out where the tax collectors at
we'd use the Intel and
capture them
who's getting the Intel the were you
guys getting it yourselves it's mostly
yeah well if we had like the nilo out of
Saigon some of our officers Captain
schaible with Mira Anderson was there
some other team guys they were getting
the information
so you'd get a Target package like oh
here's here's a grid location for a
little village somewhere yeah and they'd
be like it's it's this Hooch over here
is where this tax collector is this via
Kong tax collector the VCI yeah this is
where he's supposed to be right so we'd
go down and get him or would you just go
sit and watch and sit there for two days
and see what boats come where they come
just hidden so you do you do just like a
reconnaissance
do an assessment wait and watch how many
weapons were you mostly going in by the
water in these first three months like
just waterborne operations yeah on pbrs
and our our own lssc's and uh lcpl
it's a big boat with a minigun on the
back a couple 60s and and so would you
insert at night they just kind of drop
you off most of the time at night all
right we liked operating at night more
than during the day and then we'd sit
during the day yeah and watch it all we
wouldn't even know we didn't even know
we were there how many guys would you
have out in those Recons well would you
take the whole Squad yeah we take a
platoon depending upon
um like if we were expecting something
big
or we just do seven man teams and were
you usually a point man that's point and
rear kind of like go back and forth you
know so when I but when our appointment
went on r r he went to Australia and
then I I ran point for a while would you
carry for a weapon did you carry a
stoner yeah a stoner except when I was
with the Vietnamese and I carried an M60
you know how come you how can we carry
an M60 when you're with the Vietnamese
how can we switch from a stoner to a 60.
because I just wanted something bigger
something bigger like this like the so
like they had their M16s right they none
they'd have Stoners when we were
Vietnamese they didn't have Stoners
there was only 16s but I just felt
uh I found it something big yeah you
know and um you want that pig yeah and
with the two Vietnamese there was
another Vietnamese guy there was only
one about M60 so I made two sixties
right and um
that's just I don't know if it's a rule
I don't know if it's a logical thinking
but that's and then my buddy Bill he was
a radio man
so we're working with the Vietnamese as
an advisor I dug you know yeah when you
were doing the first three months so
you're doing Ops
you guys are carrying compared to what
we have to carry now the modern guys
with body armor and Rady everybody's
carrying the radio everyone's carrying
body armor everyone's wearing a helmet
everyone has night vision
it's like even the weapons because you
get your weapon but then on your weapon
you put a laser and you put a scope and
like it is if you put a light like
everything's just you guys look like
super slick compared to us we were and
we were quiet yeah we're a pair of
Levi's a couple you know our our stuff
where our some guys wear the stuff on
the outside but if you run around the
wrong side you'd want to put your stuff
on the inside to keep it from getting
muddy put your bandoliers on the inside
yeah you'd wear your your oh your web
Gear Well
we did if you carry if you if you if you
did it like this right if you strapped a
mother you didn't really wear web gear
right you could wear the the harness
right just the harness and then other
guys had their vests made up like what
you wearing now the events guys would go
to the parachute Loft yeah and have them
created right for their M16 uh magazines
and things like that so you were wearing
jeans though this is the one this is the
one thing about all these guys
and these frog man Seal Team guys right
oh yeah because it was better than the
bdus and all that you were you
wear Levi's and they're wet and they're
muddy and they're heavy and you get
chafed and all that and try to take a
with a pair of Levi's you know so
why'd you wear them because it looked
cool
combat qualified man you want to come
back qualified pair of Levi's so when
you got home right it makes more sense
right when you got home you're walking
along my Levi's man you know that that
was amazing from the Delta these are
from the Delta man these are yeah
whatever there's on five combat Ops you
know or what I mean that's what it was
about I make a pair of jeans right now
and we call them Delta 68s oh yeah yep
we fake a pair of jeans we call them
Delta 68s in honor of you guys wearing
them that's cool that's cool yeah so
yeah we that's that was why you know
it's because there's nothing nothing
cooler than walking downtown San Diego
or downtown Coronado with four guys that
have combat qualified Levi's on and
you're going to run into some Marines
you're gonna sit there and look at you
like
okay
it's just you know even these watches
would get you in a fight with them I was
sitting at the you know the daylight
Cafe down in in Coronado no oh the day
and night Cafe a little long boots yeah
yeah oh I've been there I'm sitting
there with me and me and Hyatt right so
we're eating and this guy comes up
behind and says oh so you look like
you're one of those little wet back frog
man
so I'm like oh if I'm gonna be one
of those nights it's gonna be one of
those nights and how it looks like a
hey the only one would
call him we went back and be me it's not
you and I don't call him that
I told him I said Lou I said be cool man
it's all right so I get done here it
says I'll kick the out of him
okay ask me so and I just almost
finished so I
finished up and I turned around
big boy oh it's a big guy I went hey man
I'm gonna tell you something and so when
I did that I just
one hand behind his neck and the other
one underneath his throat and I hung on
he moved and my my heels were still
arced on the wall you know like this and
I hung on and then Hyatt jumps on top of
the bar
karate right so yeah
you know what I'm just hanging on you
know all this kind of stuff you know it
looks like guys you're looking at Lou
you know and he's like no like Bruce Lee
whatever thing and they all like like
that you know so finally the guy he that
choked him out right and hung on it came
around and choked him up
then I got mad back hand Jim
my watch pops off into the street right
oh so then I kick him and my shoe
goes off into the street I had to secure
your gear better
I just looks at me
like that you know come on ask me let's
leave this joint so
we go out and I pick up my shoe and I
put it on and grab my watch and put it
on it this way so we he always
thinking right so we walk to the corner
and we get out there and he says let's
look so we picked from Christ are they
coming
I said not yet he says well let's get
that out of here before that big son of
a wakes up it's just like because
I got him by surprise here yeah but but
but that's when you grab hold it's like
grabbing hold of the tiger right you you
know that if you let loose
he's going to jack you up you know so
you know so you guys would run Recon
look at a Target and then when you were
gonna go hit the target what was that
what was the normal profile of a mission
like that you take Sam pans in did you
go in the night to you cool up uh we did
we did work for the the Poo program this
is a tip this is a an operation right
explain what the Prue is it's a province
reconnaissance units right so these are
Vietnamese they were Vietnamese they
were not seals the the Seal program had
its own stuff Vietnamese so they had
Vietnamese seals and then they also had
the pru
Province reconnaissance units and they
work for the company right they had a
caseworker that usually in charge of
them and the senior officer American
officer or uh an enlisted right
my buddy and I relieved those guys and
it was E4
and I think I was you for right but we
were operators right so then I already
have how many people are in a pru how
many Vietnamese did you have in one of
those groups about 40 in the group so
there's 40 Vietnamese there's and
there's two of you two of us two
American advisors right and then the
caseworker and then an interpreter maybe
two interpreters and out of that 40
probably about five or six of them you
can count on me in Vietcong did you live
with them yeah living with them on a
like a like a villa type thing
and uh yeah you just stayed with them
and then what was the op Tempo like well
probably you know we'd go out
um
it depended on the that was what was
spooky about it because a lot of their
Intel came from them
right so they could set you up they
could set you the the the guys in the
company could set you up to be hit so
you had to kind of figure things out and
that happened to us a couple times it
was and we and we got hit we figured out
there was two guys that were kind of the
um
when they were around things happened
when they weren't around so what'd you
do about that
well I told the one guy I went my
interpreter says
you know
I don't like him I think he's a very bad
man
it says have you seen you know and then
did you see what's happening with this
guy he goes
he says I take care of it so we have
another op the guy didn't come back
so because he the my interpreter that
guy was and he works with my cousin
right was good and trustworthy and
that's it see some were good and just
some have they're there the sacrificial
responsibility the thing that they feel
from their heart was right on and others
and others were victims they were in the
military by being a victim I mean the
war is going where are they going to go
yeah where are they going to go so you
were about that you were about to tell
about an OP like a standard op that you
did with the pru okay yeah
um one of our guys Seal Team one guy
comes up to us and says hey I need some
Gunners right I have like I have two
boats probably about six guys in each
boat we're gonna do a pro-op we're gonna
go get these uh Tax Collectors right
all I need you guys is to be shooters
all right so
um my officer well my lcpl black Mac was
with me me Hyatt Black Mac
and I don't know if Macintosh was on it
or not
but um so here we are in the sand pants
four sand pans right they're two
Black Mac and another guy and me and
Hyatt and we're gonna we're gonna take
the bodies we're gonna we're gonna tie
them up and we're gonna take the bodies
launch off of a set off of a PBR in Sam
pans it's cruise up this Little River
it's night time it's night time you guys
are you guys dressed like Vietnamese are
you guys in black no are you guys just
watching well see that was our platoons
too though some guys who wear black
sometimes wear black pajamas we're
Levi's other guys would be wearing green
tops you're just you're kind of makes a
match always we did a blocking Force One
Time in the army guy says who in the
are you guys you know hi this is
well we said we're we're frog men
but there's a whole we're gonna we were
going to kill a colonel in this
helicopter you know but we didn't but so
the the op I'm glad you didn't so it was
I I was saying hey gun up like that and
I'm going oh shoot we're all going to
shoot this guy why what was the colonel
doing
we were we got ambushed the arm we were
we were doing a blocking force behind
the army unit that's the other thing too
we'd work with some armies so we were
doing a blocking Force put on an army
unit
they got sniped on so this guy in the
colonel Coastline over and he throws a
CS grenade out so the Cs granny goes out
and pins his guys down they're getting
sniped at the rest of us and we're in
our different Levi some of us we're
laying up a long bank and the helicopter
lands right outside of us right
it lands right outside of us
so he comes walking along as we're
laying up the bank and and uh he walks
by hide
who's sitting there looking at us and
Hyatt says I guess you're the dumb
that do that CS grenade out
so he looks up and he goes yeah who in
the are you guys
and I said we're just the blocking Force
you know and so I'll talk to you when I
come back right so he goes over there
and he said guys they did they did a
minute back they got these guys out they
were wounded complaining one guy got
killed
but so then
he comes back out he says uh yeah well
we'll see who you guys are you know and
I said I don't give a who you are
he said if you throw another CS grenade
out of there says I'm going to shoot
your helicopter out in the air
he just looks at him goes back to his
helicopter and he gets in he sticks see
his grenade out there
blue says I've got his Stoner and he
goes like this and I'm going oh so
I grabbed mine and the other five guys I
grabbed theirs we're up there and I'm
thinking
he pulls the trigger that guy's going
down he pulls it back in and leaves
those are the guys I was with and we all
yeah they could easily get out of
control yeah you know but everybody did
maintain
all right so so back to this pru or Prue
op that you're kind of like saying was a
good one to highlight yeah
um hmm Pro the Prue advisor team guy got
this information right he says I just
need you guys to come in and back me up
because we had the Stoners he had I mean
some of those guys all they had were the
carbines right and M2 carbines and maybe
maybe a 116 and with those guys with the
Vietnamese seals you might find an M60
with the Prius you wouldn't
when stuff went down he can't call any
American Air air force or air support or
any of that stuff and they don't fly
support for anybody they were doing
everything like from the bush right kind
of like guys that worked with the
mountain yards right so he says I got to
send tell us his route to the snatches
guys as you set up security he says
we'll throw them into boats you guys
package them and we'll get our way out
of there we'll grab hold of the because
we could use our but if we're using if
we're going on the app he can use our
boats right the sand pounds alongside of
them and they can go so
so here we are Espinoza and Hyatt in the
back with the sand pad
you ever paddle a Sam pad no I have not
they're like P rows though you're
they're the p-row the like the guys in
the
um the Cajuns down in Louisiana Ohio
they're a man so we're we're
paddling is it like so it's like a canoe
yeah like a canoe but the sand pounds
are like they got they're like flat
bottom little thing and they go like
this and they're they're pretty tilty
right and and you got to paddle them and
I thought
he really I thought he really knew about
what we were both figuring we're Sailors
right we're frog man we can figure
anything out so we're paddling we're and
the rivers aren't very very wide we're
hit this bank and we're kind of going
like this and we're following these guys
up and they're
so we're stroking trying to you know get
up with them so then we go into an area
and it was like here's where the hooches
were right the hooch was right here so
the hooches are along the bank of the
river right along the bank of the river
so we came in we set up support set of
security for them he's got his present
his proves up here
and then
he's
he says okay it's the same four corner
security right anything that comes out
the walls on the two corners you shoot
them
so we're all right you know because
that's how we did it you know because in
a hooch
if you don't have your free fire you
know the two corners somebody's going to
get hurt so but anyway comes out here
you can you can shoot him these guys are
going to shoot you know the four corners
it's all right
so we're sitting down here we've paddle
in
supposed to be quiet
it turned out to be a John Wayne
fighting you know and guys okay so John
Wayne fight is where they know you're
there it means when they got inside the
cats they were in there were fighting
back you know because there was
Vietnamese they were the crew guys they
weren't they weren't Team guys you know
they weren't
they weren't us so the crews go into the
village go into the village into the
hooch and they get into a gunfight they
get into a gun and fight
fighting okay so the guy comes flying
out the hooch and the guys on the corner
you know kill him right and so then
there's this thing going on and then one
guy comes out on our side he's running
right in front of us Black Mac this is
the very first time I ever saw this
right
had an m78 grenade
launcher right and usually if you're
going through the like the dance Jungle
you carry the fleshette rounds or the
you know like canister rounds right
well this was kind of going to be in an
open area so he did an h e round and
this cat goes running they puffed one
flare then in the firefight
there was the river goes around like
this there were some people down here in
Vietcong right so when we had the
firefight they were getting hit over
there
these guys are running out the back
Black Mac shoots this guy in the back
with that
grenade I mean grenade launcher and all
they saw was two hands and two feet
flying through the air
and I remember going wow man wow
you know how everything kind of goes
slow motion and there's noise but it
seems like it's quiet you don't you know
you you uh
I don't know disconnect or whatever but
anyway it's it's all just happening and
and uh but you know you're okay right
and everybody's calling about it and uh
the guy who was running the captured
these two guys right
so
when we had them packaged up these guys
start opening up to where we were so
Vietcong started engaging you guys the
the Vietcong that were a little bit off
the Target right they're engaging us but
we need to go out over here so we grab
the two bodies put it they threw them in
because there was there was four guys
this is the op where one of my friends
said oh yeah I said didn't we capture
some generals
he wasn't even on the op
and it was in a memorial day it was in
the Memorial Day thing he shows it to me
I'm gone
so I called it was it generals that we
capture it wasn't it's just some VC I
think it was two VCI guys and a tax
collector because yeah that's what it
was it says well he said why I said
because the guy who told me about the
story says he said it was General
she wasn't even on the app
I said oh because your your stuff get
you're not and not that anybody's taking
credit for it there's there's another up
that one guy did try to take credit from
me it's called the Donk story but
okay and another so in the meantime how
do you get so you gotta you gotta leave
the area of operations right you have to
go by this group of Viet Cong right that
are engaging you yeah and they're
shooting over here right
so then we didn't know that there's
other guys on this side so they start
shooting back at these guys so we had
friendlies
those are friendlies no they're Vietcong
too oh so so there's Viet Cong on both
sides of you on both sides of us here's
the place we're going now we have these
guys here and we're paddling out between
them so you're gonna paddle out between
Viet Cong on both sides right this is
not good this is not good the one thing
that was good about it though it was a
Black Knight it was a dark night so we
weren't silhouetted on the river right
for the short time that the flare went
up we saw what was going on we knew we
were going out so we took off
but they had this thing going on and it
was like
um
about another one of those what what the
hell are we doing here right but by the
time we got out on the river because
there was a two Vietnamese sand pens and
then Black Mac and two Vietnamese in
that of the third sound fan me and Hyatt
with our guys we passed everybody
we were waiting out on the river for
these guys to show up and it's like I'm
gonna
are we lost are we where are they at wow
and then the boat because the radio was
with uh with Mac with black max so he
had the Black Mac the platoon Commander
or he was our the assistant and he made
you call him Black Mack because he was a
black man we have black Mac and we had
pink Mac it's Macintosh we called pink
you called Macintosh pink Mac yeah and
we were talking and Bimini too so I was
you know Echo was asking about uh
MacIntosh and he was like you know he
goes wait a second so was so was
Macintosh a black guy and I said I was
like no no he's a white guy he's white
as me and then he asked you the same
thing and you're like no he legitimately
had his mom was legitimately black right
well for me this was news and I knew him
like for a long time
he had freckles his last name was
Macintosh he looks like a complete white
dude I mean it makes the story even
funnier you have to concentrate on his
face yeah you see the black features if
you really start looking closer I mean I
knew him for a long time and you hung
out with him I know if you would ask me
I never would have said that guy's black
other than the fact that you know
everyone knew he was like from the
Virgin Islands right and that that's
what was that's but I just figured he
was some white guy you know that that
grew up there if you think about it
that's the way seals are
we think we know who they are but
they're not yeah yeah
don't know but anyway we we got we got
there those two guys out and and it was
a cool op and then the guy that was
running the app he he was just so happy
because he'd been trying to catch those
guys for a long time so stuff changed it
was always a dynamic the intel was
always Dynamic so something that was
good today was different it's I think
it's kind of like symbolic or kind of
like the way the Afghans is what I'm
understanding is they're moving all the
time yeah well you always have to adjust
for that and it's interesting you know
the the fact that
you know we're working with Iraqi
soldiers or the I would I didn't fight
in Afghanistan but guys that did uh work
in Afghanistan had to deal with the same
stuff you know you got these you got
these partner forces that you're working
with some of them are most of them are
good and but you got four or five of
those guys that are definitely suspect
you got two or three of them that are
bad and you know uh one of one of my
friends got shot up pretty bad
um by a guy that they thought was you
know was there to go and do do a mission
with them
um he's a special forces guy uh what
about the uh what about the Donk op what
happened with that one oh that was a
that was going on to football Island Man
and me tick the Vietnamese the kid that
was sitting beside me I loved him man
he was a guy who told me he said Espy
I want for my country what your country
has for you
says you know
he says you seals you come and then
you'll go
but I'm gonna die here I'm going to
fight here I've been fighting before you
got here this is where I'm gonna die not
hell no tick I said we're going to be
together I'm going to get out I'll I'll
become an officer and I'll come back and
I was even going to join the Vietnamese
Navy SEAL Team right that's
that's where I was going with it but I
needed a break too
I wanted to get out of you know there's
there's a thing where you realize that
if you don't have you're not all in
you're gonna you're gonna get killed and
and that's from my respect for the cats
like you and guys that have been in for
30 you know years that like Hayden like
Hayden chaldecas
um
um uh guy's not like Frisk and crawdad
and you know those guys
um sometimes there's a little break of
war between after Vietnam that space and
but then there's more of it but for me
it was like I need to get I need to get
out
uh and I had the officer to wrestle at
the University of Colorado so so there
was with tick and
so he says uh football Island was there
was a bunch of cats there and we wanted
to pull an up on it so what we did is we
did three people three seals and tick
got our little sand pan went up to
football Island
is
not any wider than this the room so like
10 10 feet across 12 feet this is this
is how big the river was or how big
football Island was no that's how big
the river was okay football island is
probably about
three clicks wide probably about two
clicks three to two clicks you know wide
and long
but we didn't have a lot of intel on it
and then during the day there was a lot
of you know they would they would move
around right so what we wanted to do is
find out how many were there so we went
in at night
went in with the tide sound pan just the
four of us
went in
called up this Little River then then it
narrowed probably to about that wide
so like six feet six feet right
but way out was the Big River and that's
what we came in on we came in with an
lssc right with the Sampan attached to
it so they launches they cruise on up
the river and then we turned in and went
did our early Bop
so
we're in there and we're sneaking peek
we got up there
probably
when we first reached the mouth of the
river we heard
she was like uh oh yeah is that them
signaling that's them signaling right
but it was right near the bank where we
were going up so sons of I mean
they're right there right so we've
stayed local you know low paddle
paddling up just kept going went by them
probably about
two minutes three minutes up you know
not not that far up maybe
maybe about five minutes so then we got
to where it was easy to pull in there
was like like a shallow bank that we can
get in so we harbored up the the boat
then we crawled up
picking up like picking up and looking
and Jesus those cats were smoking
cigarettes they had their weapons kind
of stacked and talking and then there
was this thing that went like this how
many
probably about 50. that's a big group of
cats that's a big group of cats yeah
he's like 50 years you know they were
did you have a stoner I didn't even have
a 60. we'll have no no no we're going
that's the forced owners three Stoners
and and uh tick with the 16. it's a week
okay so we could we could have fought
yeah well we don't we're not there for
that so we'd hear this
you know just but it was like a
it's like a dog it was made like a real
Hollow sound it was a little piece of
wood
little piece of wood like this had two
Serpent's heads had a whole drilled
through it and then there was a line
that was cut out that would make that
Hollow sound okay it's almost like a
percussion instrument yeah but it had a
place where your thumb would fit and
when your finger would fit I didn't know
it at the time we just heard it
so then we get up there and we're laying
out on the river we hear this oh
oh a boat and we were up there just we
were
we were just kind of hanging out for
probably about
40 minutes maybe maybe now we caught it
just When the tide was full
and then it started running out right
well the cat's out on the river hooked
up on a barge I mean on a sandbar
so the Vietnamese guys are there and
they're going and then one guy was
hitting his little donk he said oh
sounds like the Americans are stuck I go
yeah and then one guy says should we
should we go
we should get the guys and we'll go
kill him
all right we're just hanging out here
you know and
let's just take a break let's Let Him
Live tonight
and so tick was like
we're gonna have to get out of here
right so this one guy gets up and he
says I wanna die I'm gonna go take a
leak so he goes over with the little
thing and I'm laying here and Hyatt's
laying there and he takes this thing and
he puts it down this is the percussion
instrument thing yeah he puts it down
and so then Eliot was a platoon leader
right he's the one who's calling me up
I'm here ticks here and riches over here
so
all right well let's go so I'm sitting I
look and they laid it when he laid it
down it was like right in front of me
and then he started pissing between me
and Hyatt
so I mean they're like this guy like
this like you know you can feel the like
rain fitting on the top of your head I'm
sitting there going
son of a and so the other guy said
hey
you want a cigarette oh yeah so he turns
around goes back over and gives this guy
a cigarette hi it's this move man I
grabbed that thing put it in my pocket
we slid out and then we're
on the low look we're the current is
starting to move out so it was pretty
cool so we weren't like we were going
out with it
those boats are on so we get out there
and then we'd pass by the guy the shot
you know I was like
in uh
I didn't I didn't really understand it
but then Lou he says uh I could feel the
bullets going into my back man
he said I could just feel them all the
way where you just get that it's not
reality right
there there are things that
I'll get into that a little bit later
but so we went out and it was so dark
that when those guys are still sitting
there we pulled the boat up there and we
was like hey
I said let's push you off we pushed them
off the barge and then we took off but I
had that dog I put it in my pocket so I
told this story to a buddy of mine Andy
Willingham right team guy
and uh
he said that's cool man and I showed him
the little thing you know because I I
brought it back and then uh
he was in class 41.
tough guy man just
actually he had a tussle with the guy
I'm not going to say the guy's name but
his East Coast guy the real high-end
that ran a lot officer that is high
profile and we're in the Tradewind
bar and he's starting this East Coast
West Coast and Andy Willingham
tells him you know you don't shut the
up I'm Gonna Knock You Out
Andy's dad
used to bet money with all these guys
down in South and he was a relative of
Strom Thurman
and he used to knock donkeys out with
that 16 foot
while the guy goes what
out
she drinks experiences I'll catch you
later that's really takes off
that guy's a very famous East Coast seal
you know big name High name that's never
going to be in the history books but
that's how things happen then you know
it wasn't
you know the the guys that are high
order top-end dudes you know with the
big reputations and stuff like that
they're just regular guys you're just a
regular cat 100 we're all we're all like
that and I and I I think the since we're
the media gets hold of this thing and
sensationalizes everything about you
know where
that we are anti-magnetic genuine role I
mean all of that stuff right yeah but
but when when you when you're gonna
screw with the Frog man and you're out
somewhere
you're not gonna just have to kick the
hell in one they're gonna be 10 guys
with him
you don't have to prove that you know I
mean
this is this is where the power is at
everybody knows that right and and when
that goes down where's the calmness you
know and you know
the the the the one thing is that
in the millisecond of time
you're both a coward and a hero now when
goes down and you on yourself find
yourself somewhere you go how in the
hell did I get here when you can run
this
fast backwards is you can't run them
forward and each one of the instances
and says look alike they smell alike but
they're not alike you know it's a
totally different thing and each one has
its own
Evolution the same as a fire has its own
character it has its own and what what
it used to say in Vietnam it's not the
thing you see that's going to kill you
and I tell my guys in the fire
department it's not the thing you see
that's going to kill you what is
that's the thing that's sniffing around
with Jocko's name on it let's go
where is he and that's where the
training comes in and if you have the
training then you have the millisecond
of saying
and there's that spiritual thing that
says we're in the wrong place
or don't when I look at opposite you
know like like our new guys now you guys
right the young guys that get killed in
afghanist Rex like where was the
discussion
that was pretty jacked up from the
beginning but because we are who we are
we give the space and time to say I
wasn't there they were there that's
their that's they're up and and however
it went however it went Sour Whatever
happened
it's the thing that was sniffing for
them and they didn't see it
you know no matter how well trained you
are sometimes it's just not there you
know
what did you do with uh with Mac with
with SOG did you work did you do SOG any
SOG operations the the Mac vsog thing
was the proofing okay so that they had
that was their that was their yeah
that's their that's their thing yeah got
it so those little and I didn't even
know what it was they just sent me and
Bill over there so you go in there these
guys are leaving take over we're like
all right you know and the only reason
they sent us for that is because I was
with the Vietnamese seals with two uh
East Coast guys and I and I worked that
so then it was kind of like hey we want
you to because I could speak I spoke
better Vietnamese than I did Spanish
you know so did you just pick it up from
yeah pick it up from the appointment
from from tick and Quan and unlock and
all the guys
all the guys that I operated with were
Vietnamese seals that all the rest of
the Americans operated with so when tick
said yeah I'm going to be here but you
guys are going to leave us and I'll
probably die here
all of them were killed lock home tick
um all these guys
so that's how I picked it up there are
guys that went to Vietnamese language
school they didn't send me I spoke
better Vietnamese and I did then the
guys who went to Vietnamese language
school because they're personalized it
Macintosh could speak Tagalog
because he in Vietnam he said had the
little thing I learned in all the all
the Tagalog phrases right
and uh
so
I was invested with tick and I was
invested with the liberation of South
Vietnam and I think there were a lot of
I think there were a lot of Vietnamese a
lot of Seal Team guys Vietnam seals that
that's how they felt and then after it
went down I mean I talked to some guys I
said well yeah I'd like to go back
someday and I had some partners that
said so I didn't leave a damn thing over
there
ain't no reason for me to ever go back
and and I think what happens is
there's a romance
there's a
where you
romanticize the memories
right people romanticize Wars they were
romanticized of what it is or they think
about what it is I think
those of us be there see the nakedness
of it you know see the well the deal
right the flash of that changes your
life that changes everybody's life
and
and we think sometimes that you can only
see that in war we've got people in
communities that that are going through
the same thing because of trying going
through post-traumatic stress in their
own neighborhoods you know
and uh
but what I went through is giving me
language to what happened in my life
that I'm that I'm now able through
re-evaluation counseling is one where I
have the picture of who I am as a human
being
Advanced reticular therapies the vision
thing that some that some guys are doing
that they gave me
mental pictures of where I'm going and
then this lady's really helped me with
uh it's her thing it's called rewired
Creator but
but where where I've come to the point
where I'm not going to settle for
that like I said earlier you know my
convictions and my wants need to be
stronger than the than the Alternatives
that I settled for in the past that it's
okay to do this you know I can't do that
anymore
and I got to forgive myself for the sins
of my past right
that's that's a big end when I when I
was in Coronado this last time the
reunion
um I go there I go to Denny's bar and
have a beer with Mario Masters I I
mentored him I was his wrestling coach
in Colorado right bad dude and I'd
wrestle him and then be like okay you
know when you wrestling the guy and you
know he's getting stronger and tougher
and then you go oh I hang out here
a little bit more he's gonna beat the
hell out that was that was him you know
and um
I I
that that family and that relationship
and what we create for each other
um
it's beyond just a happening it's all
it's beyond just being a fragment it's
there's the whole spiritual connection
to those old UDT guys that didn't know
they went and they picked them can
you swim yeah
I remember asking one of my old World
War II guys I said what did you kind of
weapons you carry
well I sat at my crippers
my swimming trunks and my flare
uh I said what about weapons
so we're just doing Drop and pick up and
says if you missed the boat it says
you're swimming in with the fleet you
know with the guys at Atlanta on the
beaches and there's usually a marine
laying around you can just take his
weapon he didn't care
that was their character that was that's
who we're born from right that's what
the Tad pulled a frog
you know that uh
um
and she stoned man we're living under
reputation of dead men like you said to
people they're gonna sit there and say
oh that's your reputation right
but each one of our Generations
those guys behind us are building their
own generation
you know they're they're building
they're they're building where's it
going to go
if it's left to the people that operate
um
that tobacco Lewis when I came back I
was by myself he's sitting there in the
Tradewind bar
I look at him I come in and go they
still sitting there
he asked me yes
so I come over to him I say hey man how
are you doing
he grabs a
beer
as I understand
they were pretty good badass little
operator
take my drink right
see where it is the transition to being
called that not calling you and you
couldn't I didn't like now it's called
seal operators nobody would ever have
called themselves an operator the only
person that could call you an operator
is yourself is your is your teammates
the guys that were with you
and when they say that and somebody else
says it to you it never came from you
it came from the cats that were with you
and there's some cats that were never
called operators they're Vietnam they're
seals Vietnam guys they're Team guys but
um not at that level
at whatever level that is and it isn't
mean to
to put one type of operator over another
operator
you know it's just that you are
not not better than all the rest of the
operators in the world
because then them because then it
becomes the ego thing
but from here
if somebody calls you that and you
almost cry
it means something you know and and I
went yeah you know have my I drink with
them and uh
you know and I had you know you you have
these
these guys that they say that are bigger
than life and actually they're not
bigger than life they're people that
know how to connect with you
that are
um
they give you life more than anything
you go yeah I can do that I can be this
all over Chief Allen Barry Enoch you
know uh
no I was fortunate man I I walked with
some
I worked with some good people you know
did you guys did your platoon did you
lose anybody and your deployment duck
duck Maynard transferred he he rotated
with uh the Army um he's a Marine
corpsman
so that that Marine corpsman could get
some money right do the ship over stuff
and he was the one that was walking by
with Van Hoy doc Maynard and Van Hoy
were walking by when they drilled out
that 82 millimeter mortar and killed
five seals
and he just happened to be there he's
walking by and then they had I wasn't
there because I was working with the
crews but another buddy my name Dee they
were having a word party you know they
they're changing out
that was the other thing that was crazy
but anyway at that party uh because we
were coming over and they just had a
party and they were gonna still do a
little bit more operations
and Van Hoy told these is uh I'm gonna
get killed here this time is that what
the hell's about what are you talking
about he says these these guys are
careless
they're dangerous
he says that I've talked to him about
stuff he says but we're going to mess up
and they did and and he had already like
three or four trips you know
and uh and he was one he was one he was
a cool Ben Hoy was he was a rock star
and uh
you get me was the very first time we go
to Vietnam going to release relieve a
platoon then they grabbed me like this
I say hey how are you doing you're
asking
look what I think I'm shaking hands with
a dead man
as well do you think that's funny you
know they would do those kind of things
you know and uh so then I did it when I
left
yeah so how was it coming home
if you think you were going back to
another platoon like you're gonna do it
again at what point did you make the
decision like that you're gonna get out
I got the letter to Russell to
University of Colorado which was always
one of my dreams because I was raised in
Boulder and I thought man I'd love to
rest with University of Colorado babes
and booze in Boulder my hometown her
bombs bullets and
I kissed I kissed hide on the lips and I
said hey man I'm gonna catch you later
because I got I I wasn't ready I wasn't
right you know I I felt that
I felt that thing that if I if I go back
again I'm I might get whacked and I
needed to I needed that time away you
know and if I had that space and I had
that time and I wasn't ready then I'm
cheating my I'm I may be
the wink Link in you're letting down the
team in another's operation so I'd
rather not be there right
and um
so
yeah and and saying goodbye to those
guys was really hard you know
um
and then all the other stuff you know
there's the people talk about some of
the movements that are coming now about
gender and all that other kind of stuff
you know we dealt with that in the teams
a long time before that you know we're
gay guys or whatever it is you know the
um
like in in community you know we allow
for everybody to exist not in the teams
I mean the team's resolve but we were in
California
so I mean all the stuff they're talking
about now is already all the gay thing
the whole all of that stuff is
so when I went to school at CU there
were there was a lot of people trying to
surprise you about things the Viva La
Raza thing about how violent they are
well I'm back from Vietnam it's like
you know wait a minute you know uh
no I I
Vietnam veterans against the war the
young socialist republic the Viva the
Epsilon thing
is like and I was raised in Boulder
right
all this stuff's going down I'm like
what what happened in my life when I was
a kid it felt like my days were black
and white days Vietnam is a green and
black
when I came home it was all
technicolored man all chicks
getting come and ask you if you want sex
you know it's like what happened well
you know this free love and all that
other like where is where's the moral
conviction where's those things it was
like there were there weren't any what
year was it that you got out 69
70 I got back in Vietnam 16. so it's
just like the height of Mayhem in
America yeah yeah that whole thing was
going down and uh
and I remember
at a party this guy was talking about
the the Chicano movement right
as there was another kid there he was
from Del Norte and um I'm listening to
him this guy Falcon was
really an activist and I said well I
don't agree I think it's kind of
you know because I just killed
economy from Mommy I'm back here I'm
from Boulder and and I said well you're
a sellout okay I'm gonna sell out
because I love my country because of
what I did and this kid Marty Martinez
he says yeah he can say whatever he
wants and he backhands him
so that's kind of a cheap thing in it so
you don't like it let's go Outdoors
sorry so we go Outdoors
and I I forgot where I was
right
so I walked out as soon as it's the
other time that the outside Warrior kind
of got the upper hand a little bit well
what happened what happened was he hit
me right so I turned and I looked at him
and I said you I said I've been slapped
by women harder than you can you just
hit me I said just just stand by because
I'm gonna kick the out of these three
guys first your little girlfriends and
then you
said oh no no man says you gotta then it
was reminding me back when I was in
junior high fight this guy and then they
go Oh no you're okay you're cool
that's just
I says you are manipulating these young
kids into what you think it is
but they're not but they're being
manipulated and it's not creative
thought
I said so I'm gonna tell you what no I
know you could I said no no I'm gonna go
back in the party me and Freddie I said
you come back in there I'm gonna kick
you inside there out I said as a matter
of fact when I go to a party if you're
there you better leave and if I'm there
don't come in
and later on he got killed by
threatening some old guy in New Mexico
right so I didn't fit
that's my dad
hey man I said did I screw up
Vietnam and all that
I love him man he's the guy who grabbed
my face you know told me I was Don't Be
Afraid right
and my last name's the only thing I gave
you so he takes me over and makes me
stand in this we put tiles in the
bathroom not the stick I'm kind not
that is important you mean so we did
that and he had me stand there and uh
is this this is after Vietnam that's
when you asked him if you if you had
screwed up is this when I was going to
school at CU right because I came home
and they were still there
before my dad told me we're moving I
said why are you moving
we're afraid of you
we think you're going to kill us
I see why what do you mean he says the
way you are at the behavior the way you
look at us the way you carry yourself
sometimes he says we think you could
kill us
that's when I understood that's where
the outside were started looking to go
what the
and there's another couple other things
I'll get to a little bit later about
what happened but he had me stand there
he says you know the way we are is
people
he says the man can say that they own
the rivers the mountains The Valleys
even the buildings that they built says
the air
or the sea
he says but they don't
but I want to tell you something
that's quartile that you're standing on
everywhere you walk Gibby that's when
you know he loving me when he called me
give me give he's different than Espy
you know and go
says uh everywhere you walk
is paid for by you
by the blood of yours and your friends
he says and you did it for your family
you did it from your heart
so it's paid for us too
he says you'll never be ashamed about
what you did and who you are
is that
you own it
so whenever I walk into a million this
place right here right now it's mine
this is your this is yours but this
little chair here
that's mine
and I didn't understand that but
somebody has to tell you so that you do
and my dad fourth grade education told
me
in the Indian way you know
and uh
he gave me so much power I
when I came back
I didn't fit
so when I wrestled they see you it was
just wrestling
that's what I'm saying I couldn't get it
I had to go to I had to go to Five Point
I went to the Nationals two times if I
beat this one guy I would have been six
to the nation right but he ran I beat a
national champ that another guy knows
but they they ripped me off
and actually when my wrestling coach
talk to this guy so why did that happen
he said I just couldn't let that Mexican
kid beat this kid right all right I
understood that no big I'm a Frog man
you know I fought for my country even
not Def
you know I uh
I I just fortunate I had a popped they
told me that you know
when I went hunting with him one time
later as a man
uh
we killed an elk
I just back it was probably less later
in we were getting him up he says Gibby
he says uh
you hunting he says you go up over the
Ridge and says and you're scared down in
elk and and I'll kill him
I said all right so I'm up there walking
up on this room like me when my my mom
wasn't going to let him go
but she said he said what if Gibby goes
with me well if Gibby goes with you you
can go
I said dad I don't want to go he says
you you go with me I said
all right so he tells me the disorders
you go up on top he says you chase down
the elk and I'll kill him
and we'll be you know it's all right
so I'm up there humping I'm like 47
years old I can feel my heart you know
like when you're on ambush or something
like that and you feel your heart
beating in your head your neck you know
I'm thinking I'm gonna have a heart
attack up here and my dad's not coming
up here and they're gonna find me a bag
of bones right
so anyway I came down and he was driving
he had that's why I got in here I put my
weapon here you're supposed to have your
weapon but where you're hunting right
with you he said will you drive
so I wonder I drowned the truck
as soon as I got hold the door I'd heard
the sound man
somebody's shooting at us went right
over my head two of them
and I said I said what's going on I said
oh Papa's whatever's happening they're
shooting at us
and and then I grabbed his weapon so I'm
gonna shoot somebody he goes no no he
says there's the elk it's coming this
way so instinctively I drew up I was
going to shoot the elk in my day going
no no no I said that's my gun
and when we went my dad I said dad I
don't want a gun he says no I'm just
going to be with you no no you got to
have him in case you get hurt some you
got a gun
it's all right so he he locked and
loaded the round for me I shoot
clipped him like this and I took the
second shot and then I was I locked and
loaded and I'm running next thing I'm
just running after this elk
and uh
and I heard my dad as I was running he
says I'm going to shoot him again like
that no no no give me he'll fall he'll
fall
and when I got there the elk fell
and I looked at him and the elk goes
and I felt the spirit you know it's like
and they saw him die you know
and I hadn't done anything since Vietnam
right
and uh
you know like sometimes when you see
those guys and they're they're gone when
you know that the spirit was there but
they're gone
it was like that again those aren't
flashbacks people go oh they got a
flashback to Vietnam those are
restimulations you know you know where
you're at you have a choice to do and
whatever a lot of guys
themselves out they quit on themselves
they give themselves an out of being
responsible for themselves that's how I
think right and so
I looked and
I'm standing there and my dad comes up
behind me
uh and I had my H harness with my k-bar
and stuff
he said you okay and I turned out I
looked at my dad he goes
he says you're not okay he says give me
your knife he says go get the truck the
little bag
that had the hatchet and the and the
knife and the boats on all the stuff
so I go to the truck I get to the truck
and I'm like
shake it like this it goes oh man God
you know wait what what am I doing here
why did I even
so
we grab like get the truck I come back
over to him my dad looks comes over to
me
he looks at me and he gives me a hug got
me like this well the knife with the
blood yes I'm like this going
she says looks at me and he says uh
forget that Vietnam because I
need you to help me right now
hold the legs
so I'm holding the legs right we're in
this place where all the that was out
into like a pasture right where they'd
cut the the stuff down right the
um
stubble right
and operated up the plate or reads up by
Cambodia right and that was a pretty
flat place but that's what it looked
like and
I could hear isn't it like
but I could hear them in
in the heart of my mind right
thinking and shaking
and so then we got him up and everything
he caught shoots a gun his body comes
down we load him in the truck we take
I'll get him in the truck and my dad
says okay he says now we pray
right
it keeps the liver too you know and the
Indian way right so
we pray and he grasp my hand
it says heavenly father I thank you
I thank you that my son is with me
and I thank you
that you give this Elk's life to bring
him home to me
you know I'm sitting here uh pops man
come on you know so then that night I
couldn't sleep it was in like a little
tear Teardrop trailer man it was
freezing in there right we're cold my
dad's rubbing my back I said dinosaur
I'm gonna get outside so I went outside
and I looked up at the sky
and other than scan there's two times
I've seen it once when I did a Native
American sweat with a guy that was a
Vietnam vet that invited me to be part
of the American Indian veterans of
Colorado his name was Wendell Irving one
of the greatest honors of my life that
was the beginning of me stepping out of
all that
the oppression of Vietnam and
uh losing myself
losing the humanness that I was and and
uh
that piece the the young boy being
revealed right
I looked up and I went
oh man God this
this is too much these honey trips are
too much
and then it's getting in the spirit the
same way those mountains spoke to me and
said we'll be your friends forever right
and the way that Paul almost says I'm
with you and that's the way to Vietnam
um
I heard him say I heard the spirit is
like the same way that I gave that Elk's
life to bring you home to your father
I gave my son's life to bring you back
home to me
it was the beginning of
of the spiritual thing you know I mean I
I you know I'd accepted Christ and all
that kind of stuff but
it was different because then it was
blood again
like the war like a Vietnam blood again
this this the blood sacrifice of things
changes things if people knew what war
was and what the blood was like the
building in Ukraine right now they know
the Americans don't know
I mean they'll kill guys in the in you
know the the ghettos or whatever over
meaningless stuff right because you want
you want your car or you
all you want is whale tail right
I'm right now I'm in I am Jonah and the
whale right now
because I'm trying to sort things out
and where am I going with this
75 years what am I going for the next 25
years right
where where am I going this is part of
that challenge this is part of it and
where does that come from that comes
from being a frog man that comes from
not being afraid of being cold
I hate it
I hate it more than anything but I'm not
afraid of it
right
I'm not and I'm you know it's uh people
say I'm not afraid to die either you
know you're not going to know until
somebody's there to kill you
I mean that's the reality of it
I'm not I look out there and see all the
MMA guys man
they're going to go out there
the one thing that I admire about all of
them is going out there
they're the ones that's gonna know not
the cats sitting around outside that
aren't in the arena that aren't in there
getting their ass kicked and then even
even though they are which is the one
that has enough that's going to pull
them out that isn't going to be ego that
pulls them out it's going to be their
heart to pull some out those are the two
champions
there's a guy with all the talent in the
world he can kick out of everybody
but but if his heart's not right man
it's on ego he's a he's an angry person
and I and I was that angry guy one time
I sit there looking in the mirror and
going
you know the face of death was mine
like what and then I'm going to have
kids
I can see I can see some the guy was
with the three Union the young seal man
what do I do how can I do this and still
love my babies little kids
Enoch did
he would sit there and hold my babies
and very Enoch is one of the baddest
dudes in the valley and one of the
nicest guys you ever meet him Mary not
he's a true mentor of teams of he was
with crawdad you know and uh
it's bigger
um
so my pops uh
gave that to me
you know fourth grade
yeah then he
when I was wrestling
in high school he never my sophomore he
didn't go see me
and um and then one day I was dry I told
him I need to go to a wrestling camp I
got to lift weights and this and that
money some protein my coach wanted me to
do that stuff my dad says well I don't
know about that he says I got you a job
he says and uh if you make enough money
he says you can go to your wrestling
camp
he says now shut up and eat your beans
right protein I went I said what's my
job he says hang in drywall
so I was 98 pounds man hanging drywall
with grown men I had to get on this on a
scaffold I mean on a horse to get on a
horse to hold that up but there was
nobody that ever wrestled it was
stronger than me
and so all of that prepared me for the
teams when hanging on the on the
bottom ring of a helicopter in the air
and I'm 500 feet
uh going through training right through
buds training we did the drop out of the
helicopter and pick up
hanging on and no big no big deal you
know
that
how do you get there
right it's each of those little life
like things and
or knowing that
Chief Allen's on my ass you know
I was doing Drop pick up with him right
and they were telling you about what
that is and I'm sitting there going you
ever do drop and pick up you know they
don't do it anymore but I do it yeah
yeah well there was East Coast guys told
me how do you do that stuff just sitting
there just jerking out I said well you
got to be swimming backwards he says oh
really and they were teaching them to do
that you know and go so he says yeah he
says it's going to look like the boat's
gonna hit you but don't stay there and
he'll pull you in so I'm like this
oh you know I stroked out Boom
the vote goes by Chief Allen comes back
your neck brownies Espinoza don't move
he takes off he comes back I swear he's
gonna hit me again it's like
so then the third time he didn't say
anything he just turns around and comes
over and goes it's coming at me it is
really coming up kick stroking and glad
he ran over me with that boat boom man
my face piece was hanging down and stuff
and then he pulls by
last time
he grabbed me when that boat grabbed me
and I hooked hooked up he threw me all
the guys ducked as I was like from the
boat's about this big huh everybody's
duck and I'm flying through the air and
I caught the other side you know I never
ever never ever missed uh a pickup again
so what'd you do when you graduated from
college then you wrestled all all your
years of college yep I realized four
years of college qualified qualified for
the Nationals two times and then
it was like
Brad Leach was a sheriff and what am I
going to do right I was going to I was
going to teach school I was doing my
professional year teaching school
and this kid comes up I was with my
mentor my Proctor and he says uh
you see this kid walks out of the
classroom
he says hey get back in class okay look
he says you I'm like what
you know he walks out and I said hey
what
what's the deal with that he said no no
man he says uh you can't I said you
can't grab his head stuck in the logger
he says no no you can't do that they'll
arrest you
says well I'm not going to be a teacher
and I graduated and I was what am I
going to do I didn't want to teach
school so Bradley she was a sheriff and
he says how would you like to come on to
Police Department says then we'll um
start diver rescue team since you're in
the teams you can shoot and stuff and do
that
so it was like
come down do the polygraph and give me
the whole test I did everything
polygraph the drug thing I was just from
CU right I said you ever done any drugs
I'm going
what do you mean you know clarify I said
you know they gave you those pills in
Vietnam you know that speed and they
kept us awake all night that was the
only thing that I'd ever done and maybe
down in Mexico a little bit of white
pills just a party for the weekend but
uh so I thought okay smoking grass I did
so how do you justify well if you take a
lid like this and you smoke it and you
share with people you accidentally smoke
about that much
maybe a quarter of a lid huh other than
that did you do any more drugs I said oh
no okay I passed that
so then Bradley says oh yeah he says you
you're good he says well come on we'll
get you to the academy give you a gun
and you can this is for sheriff sheriff
and I went and I said okay so I'll go
home Sunday go to sleep wake up and it
was like
wait a minute
hey no way I could be a cop if I can't
take crap from a 13 year old kid I'm
gonna kill you I mean I'd fight guys at
the bar right
but if I'm going to be stalked by
somebody and you're going to pull a gun
on me I'm going to kill you so I thought
I can't do that either
so then the fire department came up
so it couldn't be a cop couldn't be a
teacher
there was a there was a there was a
movie called Kung Fu uh-huh and it was a
grasshopper stuff it's kind of like
everybody in Boulder was kind of like oh
the essence of life shoot I opened all
kinds of line I could pick up on chicks
right and talk to people and and going
to you know in school I kind of
so it's like what am I going to do
and so then they were having affirmative
action hiring for
um people of color right
200 people are going to hire one guy on
the fire department
I didn't know about it Miss Martinez
who's who my mom was going to kick the
out of calling me father right she
calls it says hey they're hiring
firefighters and Boulder are going to
hire one he said why don't you try it
so I'm like see air land and Fire
four elements of life you know just like
the directions North South East and I
mean it was all coming together and I
was really getting
sensitized to this I almost became a
Buddhist you know I was thinking about
all that stuff so I said yeah okay I'll
try it so I did and I was I was
wrestling at CU right and I was running
15 miles you know I was in good shape
and uh at that time it was push-up
sit-ups chin ups and all that other kind
of stuff so I kicked everybody's butt on
that right
I had a afro my mustache my you know
because I had a you know you got to look
cool up there and see who you know we
did the whole hippie looking thing right
and so uh
I do the interview and stuff and they're
like oh yeah you're really the Seal team
what was that I said well not really
much I said you know I got to wear
Shades wear swimming chunks and just
kind of hung out on the beach and stuff
with red boats oh okay so that's Navy I
said yeah
I didn't tell them what the team they
wouldn't know what the teams were you
know I did have a jacket had UDT on it
because Seal Team didn't have a but I
had a UDT patch right my in my fire now
it's all gone but
uh and white hitchhike comb from the
Navy
when I
when you got out when it got out nobody
picked me up because I want to know what
I fought for
right two old ladies picked me up in New
Mexico these other Mexican guys picked
me up no wonder Frisk me I had my 38 in
the back and uh I I they frizzed me but
I was sitting in the back I think I had
to pull this thing out and say okay guys
everybody out but I didn't then when I
got we were into Colorado some coyotes
were were stalking me you know I think
I'm gonna come back in Vietnam won't get
eaten by the damn coyotes then a guy in
a tractor trailer truck tried to run
over me thought I was a cow he stopped
gave me right into Colorado so anyway
that's how I got home from the Navy
but
so I said yeah I'll I'll do this took
the interviews and everything he said
well yeah but you got that uh good stuff
there boy you know and I'm all white
haired guys blue eyed you know that from
Nebraska and
I'm
uh
so I
I'll just try it I said okay shaves off
I mean my hair's been cut shorter I can
shave my mustache I'm not
okay
so I show up
um
I was drinking
you know I was still I was still over
here yes I was going I didn't know I was
going through post-traumatic stress
um when you look at the behaviors now I
know I was
but um and the behaviors are drinking
fighting all of that stuff racism sexism
you know screwed the white guys and
whatever so I'm telling you about you
know you finalize yourself as a frog man
and you're pretty clean about who you
are right
but then when you don't fit you don't
feel that you don't fit then you start
bringing all this stuff back right
that's that the socialization piece
because that's easy to fall back into
right
so I got out of the fire department
I was like this guy says uh yeah kid
you know where you belong he says uh
we're going to get along fine on this
department right
so I put up with that for about
well
five months later I was drinking and I
was it was already the beginning I I
lacerated my liver
three holes in my duodenum
I got this this cut here I have one down
my leg that's right in my liver riding a
motorcycle
drinking and I'll going back over to
Denver
the one thing cool about those guys was
they covered for me because I had no
sick or vacation we worked every other
day for three days and we're off four
days so if you have 10 days off you had
an offer a month
so 20 guys 20 shifts recovered for me
and I paid those shifts back when I got
back to work but I kept my job
so I'm going well that's pretty cool
waking up at seven o'clock in the
morning the same thing I was waking up
at seven at night if you're drunk
and every other day thing has got to
call up oh I'm sick yeah you know
I'm calling in sick they go well you're
on a four day you don't come back that's
when do I go back three more days oh
so I'd use all my sick my vacation
there's times I wasn't coming to work I
mean it was
it was hard because it was so free I
didn't have
structure structure and even when I was
wrestling in college my wrestling coach
I wanted to go back to the I want to go
back to war I'd be drunk I'd smoke a
cigarette in the bar and saying hey man
I just want to let you know I want to
leave
Shelby Wilson Olympic champion
he said well Gil says if you want to
quit I'll tell the team you can go
son of a gun
so I didn't quit I struggled the last
you know they struggled you know staying
in college because of that quit thing if
I I couldn't let them
I couldn't let myself down to let them
down because I have never quit anything
in my life
right
so
so close so how long did it take like at
As A Firefighter at what point did you
start to kind of
figure out that maybe all this drinking
wasn't so good for you maybe that you
were
uh had some stuff you needed to sort out
well finally found who I was right I'm
on the first fire call I go out
put a cup of coffee down we go out going
to call and there's this guy trap like
this in a vehicle or in a building in a
vehicle car wreck so I'm looking I'm
like what do I do you know it says here
hold the whole skid so we're doing
extrication we'll tell you what to do
car catches on fire open up
I'm like all right
so I'm sitting there watching this guy
and they're trying to get him cut open
and stuff and and I remember it had that
I'm not gonna drink anymore
uh I'd had that I think it's a diuretic
so anyway I uh took a cup of coffee
right first cup of coffee man sit there
and boom get a call I put it down we
take off
I'm sitting here watching this guy and
uh all I all I could think of when I was
watching was
look at me why don't you just hurry up
and die because I know you're
gonna die my coffee's getting cold you
know that's where I was
so they cut him apart and he died right
so we go back I grabbed my cup of coffee
take a sip it's cold and I went
okay
what's happening what what's happened to
me
when my dad told me he says don't forget
that you're a human being right and I
saw this go down and I had no feelings
nothing
is like
getting disconnected over in over in
Vietnam getting disconnected that
this space and time
um and not discharging you know because
when when you're there I wasn't disco
charge anymore I wasn't crying I wasn't
laughing I wasn't mean
even now sometimes some kids just say
Well Mr espinos really doesn't have a
sense of humor because sometimes I don't
you know even on the fire department I'd
look at somebody and they'd say well I
think this guy's trying to kill me you
know but so it was like
okay that was the thinking about it and
I I became very best friends with this
guy named Billy Duran
he was an Air Force guy right he's a
firefighter
so
as I got on the fire department they
told me you remember where you belong
and this and all that kind of stuff and
then about the fifth year I mean four
years
because it was easy I was drinking I was
getting paid good money I spent most of
my money on a bar Tap I'd buy in for
everybody you know I wasn't even taking
vacations
I'm just using my time and drinking and
fighting and whatever
and uh
I was not happy
it's kind of like
um
what am I doing here
so then there was a training fire I was
the second guy I was I was I was the
third engine to go in and do this
training fire so the training fire is it
they set a building on fire that's going
to be demoed or something like that so
they're just taking advantage of a
building that's going to be demoed what
they were doing is they were doing smoke
training and in the Smoke training there
was a new lieutenant so this older
Lieutenant was trying to
see how it kind of Macho Manny was see
whether he could really fight fire and
what kind of a smoke usually was I was
at another station Billy Duran and this
other young kid had one month on the job
well if you burn tires it's a
hydrocarbon
the temperatures in this chicken coop
over the period of Time series three or
four other Evolutions that happened in
that same building it lowered the flash
point right so at one point it ignited
killed Bill Duran killed the other kid
the lieutenant that was in charge he
suffered some burns the lieutenant that
was in charge of the engine company 80
percent burns on his body so he died you
know he got burned up and Billy died and
for me it was kind of like
there was there was something was going
on too because I was pretty violent and
previous you know when when that
happened
I got fed up with everything right
and
so one day I
know I know I felt about not having any
feelings
built around getting killed all this
petty ass those like
for instance a black guy was walking
with a girl right and I'm sitting there
and they go look at that and I said look
at what it's that black guy with that
woman white woman
what do you think about that
that's what I think about it is it was
me walking out there for that woman
you'd be on the inside looking at me and
saying look at that guy what's he doing
with that white woman
you know that's what I think about it
you know doesn't mean nothing to me and
so then it was so then I got fed up with
that so I was in a dive Locker right
because I'm doing diving
kind of trying to reorganize the dive
team at my level
and one guy was talking about he had a
little booby trap cleaning up petty ass
you know kind of like cleaning
up he was an officer
set me up that I didn't clean up the
space in uh on the engineers room so I
set one up in the officer's room he
didn't clean it up he got on me for not
cleaning up mine so I got on him but not
cleaned up his he said why didn't you
just clean it then I said why didn't you
just clean yours as a matter of fact I
grabbed hold of the door closed it he
says what are you doing I said I went to
it man today you kicked the out of
me or I kicked the out of you
because I'm tired of all your white man
and all of this traditional
firefighter
he goes whoa whoa wait wait a minute go
wait wait what do you mean I said where
you from
so I'm from Lincoln yeah I said where's
your people from well we're Germans
it says
were you razor I said no I said well I
was raised here
my dad were from the pikris Pueblo so
I'm from I was born in Colorado
I said did you ever kill a comedy from
Mommy
it was what
I said did you ever you ever in the
military did you ever kill a comedy for
mommy man
well no you know I'm not I'm not in the
military I says well they don't give me
this about where I belong and or
anything else he said whoa wait a minute
ago I don't know where this is coming
from I said we don't know where it's
coming from this is affirmative action
that all you white guys are
talking about it says and I'm not buying
into it I'm a Frog man
it goes well wait wait wait a minute he
says you know
on this fire department if they have
fires
they want you with them because you're a
good firefighter
extrication now you're good you're good
at education they want you with them
they go into a bar fight they go into
the bars they want you with them because
you know most of the guys anyway in
Boulder right
EMS they know you know EMS
and they can count on you on the engines
says but there's more to being an
all-around firefighter
and you're not doing it
I said what yeah what's that he says
coming to work on time
coming to work not being on suspension
and not being
um hungover
boom man in my mind I heard my dad
saying Gibby
the only thing I gave you was my
reputation my my last name don't bring
dishonor on it and then he says you know
I said what the I don't give a I
says I'm getting connected to go to
Saudi Arabia as a weapons instructor
got connected to it was called Brown
magazine Soldier Fortune Magazine I
already got accepted and they're going
to give me a hundred thousand for the
year but
if I got killed they'd my family didn't
get it it was totally disconnected total
you know
and I said I'm that's what I'm doing so
I don't give you but then I was
going to put my two weeks notice that
was a Friday I was gonna put my two
weeks notice in and be gone
he says well when you do that
he says everybody's going to be glad
that you're gone
because your reputation sucks
so I went over to the door I opened it
up I stuffed out and I closed the door
and left him in there I went over to the
the dorm where the beds were and I laid
down I thought
I can't leave here until my reputation's
right
so the next day I go to Monday I go to
the chief
so I'll tell you what man it says I'm
going to come to work on time I'm not
going to be hungover I'm trying to Max
up my my vacation days my six days and
that's why I'm giving you my word is a
as a man
my word period not as a man I'm giving
my word
okay Gil that's cool everything's good
and
um he actually gave me some space
one of my Battalion Chiefs told me he
said Gill and my cousin Davey
when I beat up a guy real badly and my
bad Chief sit there and he says Gil I
don't know if you need a priest a
psychiatrist a doctor a counselor or
what
but I don't know how to deal with you
I said well I'm a man man on what a real
man is I don't need anybody and there's
nothing wrong with this with me the
whole world's jacked up but I'm not I'm
right everybody else is you know so
anyway I made that commitment to him
two shifts later I'm in fire
I fall in a hole my lieutenant Falls
over me and terrorists later on
tore my ACL out
but I'd give him my word
so I aged up my my Acer at my knee
for a month
and and worked like that and so then
later on we're doing training fire
um
and I jumped off the apparatus and it
caught my leg just right ah man so then
I went to the hospital and I they said
oh yeah you tore your meniscus and your
ACL has been torn for a long time so
then I had to know how to rehabbed
so that was the beginning of me now
becoming a firefighter that I can't
leave until I get all this all this
stuff straight and so then the part of
being revealed again
when when I've got on that job
my when we moved to Boulder my dad's
first job was working at fire station 2.
shoveling snow he was a laborer so he
comes home and I said how would you do
today Dad
I was like
10. well it was after the hunting right
maybe 11. no when I was younger I was
like before the hunting thing so I was
at the fire department I was what were
you doing so I was working with the fire
department what'd you do
I shoveling snow off the roof I said oh
I said what were the firemen doing
oh they're in there smoking cigarettes
watching TV and drinking coffee he says
I think I could do that job you know I
said yeah he says yes I could do that
job I said cool so
I became a firefighter
my mom when I became a firefighter has a
little piece of paper it was in a book
it's called the first Latinos in Boulder
County
and I have a copy of it and in it is a
thing that I wrote when I was in fourth
grade or third grade I was a shitty
handwriting so when I grow up I want to
be a fireman I might ring the bell I'll
wear the rubber coat the the rubber coat
the boots and the hat and we'll go on a
fire truck real fast and I'll ring the
bell and I might sleep in the fire
station she gave that to me and I went I
didn't even know it right
so my first assignment is station two I
walk in with my bunker goats called my
stuff
the same station that my dad was right
let's put your girl up there a kid all
right put my gear up and I walked
walked into the lounge I looked out the
windows where I know my dad was looking
in
and in here
right
I love God because God talks to your
spirit you know those things and it's
always a good thing it's never ever God
telling you oh you up or you're
bad or you're whatever it is it's like
hey
now you guys are on the inside
hey Pops on the inside now
so so there I was it was a firefighter
in
uh
and I did have a little a little bit of
trouble I was blessed by this guy named
JJ that became my lieutenant
and when I got there he says uh I heard
some stuff about you and
what how are we going to make this work
then I already made that commitment it
says I'm gonna tell you what you treat
me like a man
not like an idiot or a baby or anything
else so we're gonna get along I said
don't mess with me
she disagreed
and and he actually was my mentor as a
lieutenant and then he became a captain
so I became a lieutenant and then when
he was a captain Battalion Chief came up
he's the guy who came up says I think
you should be the bad Chief one position
I said I don't know what being a bad
Chief I know but you would be the guy
how how many years was this into your
career 10 about 10 years I did a good
turnaround once their first five years
of kind of
oh yeah it was bad being a jackass it
was horrible when she squared that away
then you turned around yeah and really
got on the path of the doing the right
things they commitment right that
commitment of to myself to not let
myself down for my dad for this gun was
I can't do that you know so yeah it was
it was the 10 years and then
um
I remember when he told me to go for bad
chief
and I tested and then I became the bat
then all the sabotaging beliefs come in
like you're I mean you're too small
you're not smart enough you're not all
this all the that something
going on here we go again I'm driving a
fire truck I'm a bat Chief I didn't
realize that everybody in the county
hears what the bad Chief says on the air
and uh that's a lot of pressure that's
like being Incident Commander right I
mean you got the op and stuff all the
air op stuff all the stuff you say
everybody hears everybody knows
everything that you said or think about
right
I'm driving down the road I'm going oh
my god I've got a panic attack man I
pulled off the side of the road and
going what the hell did I what are you
doing here what the you doing here
and so I called up this lady who's part
of the reevaluation Council I told her
what I was how I'm feeling she said okay
this sounds kind of weird but she said I
want you to say this I am totally and
completely incapable incapable and
incompetent to be the battalion chief
I said what she said yeah say that so I
went all right I'm totally completely
incapable and incompetent to be the
battalion chief so well what do you
think about that I said well
that's kind of kind of I don't know I
just kind of I can't it's hard I'm
having a hard time processing that
she says okay so now say this
I'm sorry I said it again I'm totally
completely incapable in common being the
battalion chief right but
fortunately or unfortunately I am the
very best person to be the battalion
chief
so I said that I went so what do you
think about that well
yeah I probably am because it was spooky
because at that time if you were became
a potential if you weren't in Union
anymore and that's why a lot of people
didn't want to leave the union because
if you screwed up you're gone
that is the sacrificial responsibility
piece that's the piece that says
okay
I was going to write a book my book was
gonna be called Frogman Out of Water
right
because that's
where I was at now it's changed because
of my fire I was going to be frog man
out of fire because there's a whole
nother Dimension about losing everything
that you ever had in your life what I
just went through with this fire
everything I ever had except my kids
the greatest treasures
in my life right
and
being good with them and being bad with
them being a great father with them and
being a bad father with them being a
good Mentor with them and not maybe not
being a good as good a mentor as I could
be
in those three spaces my dad he filled
those spaces I would hope that I can
fill those spaces for my kids that's why
even sharing this with you is part of me
trying to write my story so that those
things these Dimensions the flavor and
texture of my life they understand who
their grandpa is
this is important that's all I that's
all I have to leave them
right
what what comes from your heart and what
you say when when did you end up having
kids
I was 33.
so and my young my oldest is 40 remember
41. so were you in the fire department
when you started having kids yeah I got
on
I met my wife
that was crazy
uh I was steaming man oh she's a
Christian girl I was demon and let's go
I met her sister her sister right and
then she comes in and it was like
I I wrote a poem it says you she glowed
with the light it was night I didn't
know why but I cared
and she's led me softly and gently into
the knowledge of love and in may we
three what we want right when I asked
her to marry me because that night she
I'm like wow man she's hot I mean there
was a there was a devil fighting with an
angel man because uh the devil told me
don't go over there God's told me go
over there don't go over there so find
my buddy Andres goes Jesus Christ men
yes you never have any trouble talking
to girls go over there and talk to her
so I
I said hey uh
would you like to dance so I don't dance
I said well why not so I'm a Christian
that's what I'm a Catholic and says that
but I dance I am not dead he says no I
don't I said
so my buddies looking at me so you don't
want to lose face I said well you mind
if I sit down
I don't know good sure so I sat down he
says oh
so it kind of went on so finally she was
going to live to dance with me and that
was in the days of platform shoes so I
was a lot taller than her
as a matter of fact maybe she says I
thought you were taller
I love those things but but anyway we um
we did dance and then it was like and
that's what I think maybe when we talk
in the spiritual sense where God was
trolling with her because all I want to
do is get laid I mean that was that was
it right being in the teams the whole
the whole sexism thing the anger thing
the race all of that those behaviors
and then eventually you know it was like
I I liked what she had I liked
what I was missing you know
and that's what I'm saying that even
after you accepted Christ or you get
into the Christian thing that you'll let
loose of it you'll go somewhere else
because this the Alternatives as you
settled for in the past if you don't
keep it in front of you it's like SEALS
or guys that operate but they don't keep
the basic training in front of their
face and so then they get killed or they
hurt somebody
or they don't pay attention to it and
that's what happens that's the way the
world is it's this this is a way that
it's the way that the world is and if we
don't take care of it then we are like
sheep led to the slaughter man we're
going to be taken out somewhere you know
and so doing this is part of that
the fire department saved my life
because of that being able to party or
whatever that was and then the
responsibility that I had as a bad Chief
to keep my guys alive
to change to attella Captain it has 20
years on the job hey man I need you to
do incident command I need you to wear
your bunker gear I need you to wear your
coat I need you to tell me where you're
going and this and that and he's telling
me
I've been doing this for 20 years you've
only been on your 10 years and you won't
tell me what to do
then the Frogman stuff comes out I go
yeah
so well you don't know as much as I do I
said no but I do know about being in
combat I know about getting shot at I do
know what the war we're fighting I do
know the training that we need and the
other thing I know is that
chief gospel's wife told me a long time
ago if I get you killed I'm in trouble
Karen is the one that I'm worried about
and so for me to tell you to put on your
bunker gear and everything else is easy
and I'll write your ass up if you don't
you wouldn't do that to me I said try it
oh God so good man there's a fire alarm
go to your grade school man they go out
on a fire alarm he gets off the truck I
just follow him just two engine response
and then me I roll up
sit on the corner I didn't go arrive
while I didn't tell him I was responding
I just followed him
and uh I don't have to run on a fire
alarm so I'm waiting to watch him get
out of the truck and he looks down the
street sees me
gets back up in his truck puts on his
helmet grabs his gear throws it down
puts on his coat puts on his stuff he
looks at me and he goes in the building
he said he's got 25 and he was 25.1 at
that time was engine one I'm a rival
sprinkler alarm
third floor
so we've heard that nothing visible I
just left that night
uh
and this is where I learned a lot about
about his example too was if I'm going
to have this stuff going down with
somebody an officer good officer takes
that especially an EXO or something like
that to another room not in front of the
people
so he said can I talk to you I said yes
the
my his office because the cabin had one
he said yeah
he says you wouldn't have wrote me up
would you so I saw you
okay just like I said
yeah we
so okay
after that he talked to me on the radio
because when we were fighting fires he
loved to see me show up because we'd
gone into some fires where other people
are bailing out so he knew how I would
fight fires and I gave him that respect
he gave me that respect and my whole
shift after a while all the promotions
were coming off my shift
because I wanted to do what we did in
the teams I want to teach you to take my
job
I want you to be better than me if you
know more than me and you're better than
me when things go down
oh you'll see what I can see
that's what I loved about the team so
for for Mr one of my misters saying some
stuff and then for one of my teammates
going are you crazy
why are we gonna do that well and it
wasn't like well
who has the bigger sword right it's like
tell me why
because of this
yeah it makes sense
so that's why when we look at the
history of the teams Mike my my era and
your era is that I don't know and I'll
never be able to but that's what I want
back in the teams that's what I want on
fire departments I want I want all my
guys to know more than me because I mean
there was like
oh why do we want to do Hazmat
because I brought Hazmat in I because I
was the little guy on the end of the
ladder I did ice rescue way different
that's where the Gumby suits came from
me because they shoved my ass out there
with bunker gear on well hell no I'm not
going to do this there's a better way
ice diving Wheels ice dove in wetsuits
there's dry suits there's stuff that we
can wear right Swift Water right
teach guys how to be around Swiftwater
because if they don't know they die
that's that's the thing if you don't
learn something you die the consequences
of our mistakes the consequences of our
business being in the teams being in
Fire and being a cop
right yeah and and uh so I
so you mentioned this a couple times but
it's a very uh horrible and ironic
end to your fire careers that when you
when you you retired from the fire
department and you ended up losing
everything yeah in a fire yeah and was
it it's the uh it's the Marshall fire
December 30th 20. this is just just what
last year it'll be a year coming up 2021
New Year's um this fire breaks out
you're retired yeah you're just enjoying
life Yep this fire breaks out in in
Colorado wind gusts of 115 miles an hour
there's 6 000 Acres burned 184 sorry
1084 structures either totally destroyed
or damaged
500 million dollars worth of damage
um two people killed some other burn
injuries
and one of the things that burned was
your house yeah how the how did this
happen in Old Town that's my house is an
Old Town Superior
they're still looking at the causes of
it but they do know that fire happened
and then the wind gusts came in like you
said at 100 miles an hour
and when that when the fuels are that
way there it's like you ever take like a
like a torch when you're doing heating
of pipe yeah and go that's the kind of
fire it was it was a superheated wind
driven fire and so the contact is not
only just a conflagration of one
structure to the next structure it's
also
the the Heat and fire generated by the
by the winds right so did you get
evacuated you know where I was no idea I
went I went and got my ex-wife because
there's a marine right a little Marine
uh red rich
he said yes I'm at the bowling alley you
want to come down and watch me and he
always invites me but I never go he's a
muffler guy and I'm going so I he says
well I'd like to see Rose because we
were this was just a normal night like
you didn't know anything about a fire
because this thing happened nothing
nothing so just a normal night he says
you want to come watch me bowling
bowling yeah so I go I put on my seal
trade and put on my Marine the flat
jacket with the seal dragon on it so
we're gonna go see the Marine you know
put on a crappy shirt put on my boots
left my dog Chief in a kennel right I
put him in the kennel because he eats my
stuff
so I that night that day I told Rose
I'll pick you up usually she would come
to my house then we would go if she'd
come into my house her house would her
car would have been burned up I had a
little Jaguar that my buddy a team guy
had sold me it was in there I had my
coat and we took my truck
I'm in Denver at the bowling alley I get
this call from a neighbor hey girl yeah
you got a reverse 9-1-1 you got to get
out of superior did you get it I said No
at reverse 9-1-1 is going to make
notification that something's coming
well I wasn't I didn't get that
notification uh for some reason I wasn't
on the on the Callback
I said really he goes yeah prior to that
the girl that I was dating we'd broken
up she called me too and said hey
um do you know there's reverse 9-1-1 I
said yeah that I didn't know at that
time
uh she said well I can go down and I'm
not in town I can go down pick Chief up
I said nah I don't want to be beholding
to her right
I'll find somebody and so then that's
when the other neighbor called me up I
said no I didn't know him well enough
I'll call one of the other neighbors
guys that were in my neighborhood
they were all gone they were up on the
hill watching the fire
so then I got the call back from the
first guy he says guilt he says my buddy
that was down there says broke your door
down
and he's got your dog
as he broke my door down because I don't
lock my doors you know that's that kind
of the community he says yeah she broke
your door down and says broke my door
down he said don't be mad I said I'm not
mad but he had to break my door down he
goes yeah because I just
thinking is evacuation not the fire and
so then uh
um
and the other thing too and then I also
I asked the guy later on when I got him
when I picked up my dog I said well did
you close the door
because
if the door is open I always leave the
upstairs open so that my dog can look
out so then what that does is it creates
a draft it creates a trap it's chimney
right so that doesn't sound good
so two days later because they wouldn't
let us in two days later I called
another one of my firefighters from
Boulder and said hey so can you get down
and check it out so I'll check it out
chief
So and I've already been retired for 10
years right
2012 yeah did you see it on the news
yeah yeah but it wasn't showing real
close-ups everything was from way back
you know and that and they were saying
that old town was affected but they
didn't talk about the devastation
because nobody was getting down there
and so
I'm like well whatever
only easy days yesterday man can they
change the temperature of the water no
right
that's what I mean
the development of that
the revealing of who I am was that
little boy of gone
hey I can only take care of what I can
take care of right
and uh one of one of my friends friends
well actually Rose to my ex-wife right
her friend said I can't believe he's so
calm about it
you know other people I can't believe
you're so calm about it
time and chance man a guy gets killed
you don't get killed
what can you do about it you can have
you can have feel bad about it but you
can't change it you can have the
emotions right when we talk about things
we tell story
and we have these because it's emotional
right
but it's emotional because it starts
creating in you
that piece about who you really are it
starts opening it up for you to see
yourself to say hey I am going somewhere
good or I'm not
going to tell me who's mad at God ah God
why did God do that I'm a Christian I'm
a bishop and all that other kind of
stuff
for me it was like why would I be mad at
him he didn't start eight right and he's
invisible anyways invisible God I'm
having hope and invisible thing that I
can't see anyway and and he's given me
another house to live in he rescued my
dog right I mean whatever the deal is
and
so and then the guy tells me so now this
is the firefighter that you that you
knew that you said can you go check it
out oh the the No No the firefighter
that he went and checked out he calls me
up and says I said how are things he has
better than you Chief I said yeah well
what's left he said nothing
I just really mean nothing he says
nothing there's what about walls roof
nothing so I went over and I looked with
my family
the asphalt shingles are usually around
they were dust
there were no there were no two by fours
in the walls the only thing was left
were gusset plates things that were
metal like stove
I had a wood burning stove the only
thing was left was the top
you know
um washer dryers all gone everything
I looked at some pictures online and it
just there's nothing left but sort of
the concrete foundations right and then
they took my foundations out that's the
other thing man
I felt the full force of water
right
through the serve right and if you're
not prepared for that it'll Jack you up
gotta see if it's sniffing for you right
fire
error
you don't have that shoot on you're
gonna die right
land the land Warfare man it moves it's
always Dynamic the war piece right all
the jumping just jumping out of boats
and throughout the whole recovery thing
and Fire
I thought I knew fire
I put out a lot of fires and been to a
lot of fires but that one it was totally
consuming so when it talks about Sodom
and Gomorrah being completely gone
that fire is
um
you know and people would sit there and
say well they really humbled you right
no fire the water all that that whole
that whole thing The Humbling piece was
the generosity of people like Mama Lee
for her to call me up
say hey I understand uh you've gone
through some stuff I don't even know who
she is you know yeah
so I like to I always want to confirm
your number I want to you know I want to
help you out
and uh you know what she did she sent
you know I said look man I said
uh
if you heard get to Colorado I need to
give you a hug and then so then I did
and that's where I ran into you right
that fire
this other guy came up is revitals the
name of the organization it's a
firefighter's deal the family the fire
family too right and the Frog family
they set up they set up the uh Navy SEAL
fund for me right a guy Julio
Fitzgibbons calls me of ASB yeah uh do
you know him yeah
he asked me yeah he says uh class 42
right well yeah I said what were your
top medals what so what were you talking
about
Purple Heart Navy combination with the V
Combat Action ribbon okay thank you
goodbye
so what the hell is that about so then I
get a call from dozenbach do you know
him it anyway there and so he says this
is I think I I think that's Dozer yeah
yeah it is okay yeah yes Chris Chris
Chris Dozer yeah he says yes he said
well I got your name from Fitzgibbons he
submitted your name into the Navy SEAL
fund I said for what
this is we're going to do a fundraiser
for you
I'm like what
and he says yeah I said we'll get back
with you hangs up
so I'm like what the hell's going on
here you know and then uh
this revital guy named Jordan long he's
he's a firefighter right and he was a
firefighter that went through some
um emotional stuff
quit being a firefighter but he since
then
um started intervention for
post-traumatic stress firefighters and
cops really helping them out and so he
calls me up so I want you to come down
to this place uh you have any coats I
all I had was that seal coat my best
coat was burned up all my gloves were
burned up my best I'm wearing the Ragged
most raggedy shoes that I ever had so I
show up and and I loved my great coat
right
so he has a great coat there and the
gloves is here and says you take these
with you I'm like it was a warmer coat
than my coat so God gave me a coat that
was warmer than the coat that got burned
up right give me some shoes they're nice
and some gloves
and so then
this is how the world goes around right
he he says I got this furniture
um this firefighters
whatever the
um
brother-in-law brother isn't getting
married but he has furniture and if you
want to go up and look at it
I said all right I've been Dylan up in
up in Bailey Colorado so I drive up
there let's get her to do this again
it's all you have furniture upstairs
we'll go inside he says and this is my
cousin he's in the garage right oh I
said nice to meet you
um I said I'm jealous but no he said no
he said you're Espy
I'll look it up and go what he said your
SP says uh says he said I know you I
said where do you know me from he says
you're in sealed team with my dad Tom
Dixon
he goes no yeah I knew him when he was a
kid right
so there's that Tom Dixon thing right
seal
I grab all my furniture I take it back
the house that I have whether it was
referred to by a cop referred me to
another guy and they got the house that
I'm renting right now
I'm with my daughter and we're looking
around and she says Dad and she said
look at this house I'm going yeah it's
pretty cool though it says no he says
with the floor pattern
floor layout it's the same as Grandma
and Grandpa's house in Pueblo
two bedrooms on the side front porch
kitchen a little little basement
and and the chief has a fenced yard he
didn't even have a fenced yard where I
was at I just have to yell at him you
know he has a fenced yard I got
furniture from another team guy I mean
you know that knows that guy
um
and now I'm meeting two old guys in the
park the dog park that I go to
um and I didn't really know too much
about you then but this kid's name is
artem right he's uh he he watches your
stuff he says oh what are you doing he
says well I don't want to go down and do
a podcast with this guy Jocko oh I know
him
like why no no he knows your deal I'm
going well who is he you told me about
you and he goes yeah she says and
there's another guy named Michael he's a
big guy I go yeah he says yeah so I want
to bring her some shirts you better take
some extra large
you don't see how the circle is
right
and and there are no coincidences
you know and that fire
uh
I thought I was a seal
I
thought
you know there's this thing A friend of
mine she told me says I think you say
that you're not a seal you don't
identify with it but I think you do
because you got a lot of seal stuff you
know so then I started feeling insecure
about that I thought well maybe she's
right
but all my stuff is gone my medals and
people have given me back I'm
consciously I mean I got like some coins
and so I kind of I'm hesitant about
getting all this stuff back because now
I gotta keep it or I gotta put it on the
wall or I I just got this thing from
Frogman
um Distillery it's called Uh art the art
of
art of the spirit Distillery
his name's Paul we tapped a keg for Mike
Thornton and I was there for that one of
two seals right now I got a hat you know
and I got two bottles of whiskey that
and I was like oh
I don't want to get too much you know
and um because I'm I'm thinking trying
to trying to build my house that's the
other thing is recovering
the the
uh the gap of insurance and all that
kind of stuff right and I got one
firefighter that's a builder that's
going to help me have one guy who's son
I coach wrestling he's a big Builder
he's going to help me
but
um
I swear do I feel comfortable in here
right
I feel more comfortable with the with
the firefighter is going to help me
nothing against the other guy but
uh
how do I feel in here right so then
that's gone by
I don't let's that's the challenge you
know
yeah that's uh uh definitely a
devastating story
um but I'm okay with it yeah and that's
the amazing thing I was going to say
it's a devastating story for you to be
sitting here talking about it like
not quite with the shoulder shrug but
like almost with a shoulder shrug of
like hey guess what I got a better
jacket out of the deal
and Mama Lee um I always mentioned her
charity uh America America's Mighty
Warriors dot org we always mention that
and the Navy
sealsfund.org that's another group that
helps out my buddy Drago that's oh yeah
yeah Drago started that and his wife
Rachel yep and she's a great friend of
mine and and just and so uh anybody that
wants to help out organizations that
help out these are two organizations at
Navy sealsfund.org and America's Mighty
Warriors dot org those are two awesome
organizations
um that help out this is one case of
where you know a guy that didn't even
ask for it but somehow they figured it
out they figured me out it tracked me
down you know it was wonderful well I
think that probably gets us up to date
of where we are now
um
Echo Charles you got any questions yeah
what do you weighing now
about 155. there you go what's that
what's that workout program that you're
because you're 75 years old and it looks
like if you wanted to step out on our
wrestling match you'd give some people a
run what's up
what are you eating it's a Rolex watch
what are you eating what do you eat
um
I'm not just some protein uh do a little
bit of stuff called the Super Pump uh as
far as supplements go
but I struggle to eat I I hate eating
man but I eat fish and chicken cool you
know what about them beans your mom was
pushing down your throat yeah I'm done
with beans I do like going to Bob's
Diner in Louisville and get myself a
um that's my that's my little fix uh
where was Rancheros with chorizo and and
sometimes the Bloody Mary what about uh
what about your PT program that I work
out every day what do you do
lifting right just just in tries I do
all the splits old man splits chess
tries backing by his shoulders and traps
legs something along those lines legs
legs legs front legs back I'm giving you
75 man it's like oh yeah yeah I do the
front fronts and back you know but I but
I do something every day cut my ankle
hurts so badly that I don't do a lot of
cardio if I do cardio it's on the stair
stepper take it up just one minute at
one one minute at two all the way up to
ten you know and then back down
and then that's pretty much it I don't
know like I said I think genetics you
know and my dad was my dad was a
drywaller man he did that stuff till he
was 81 years old on the ladder weren't
on stilts with the cigarette in his
mouth I'm looking I had firefighters who
wouldn't do that you know I'm like are
you nuts so then I had to move him in
with me and actually
um Serena went to college at Colorado
State University in Pueblo and she
watched him for three years watching him
do his he's amazing man he uh gave me
all that uh
uh love I guess you know yeah wasn't it
wasn't it you know he wasn't afraid to
share himself
and I and I was coaching wrestling for
well four years ago for four years
the number one rule
don't hurt the coach
I'm getting me wrestling in tussling if
they got in someone said okay yeah stop
don't hurt the coach you know and I
didn't realize my my shoulder was so
screwed up you know
and uh so I at some point I needed a
shoulder replacement at some point I
need to do my ankle I'm going to try and
find this Navy dock if you ever gets at
the VA ever helps me do the community
care to get that done but
um
no it's
my brother five years old man had me
doing stuff when I hit the teams
climbing that rope or doing that stuff
is like a piece of cake you know and uh
but it is it is
it is that time that's mine
you know and I and I do and I do really
look at it revealing the little boy man
you know because I don't I didn't I was
living myself with the outside Warriors
so much that I destroyed so many
relationships
that I didn't have to destroy
and uh and an understanding that I am
worth loving them where I am a good
person you know and uh but now after
where I met with the I'm back into the
nakedness again it's going to be
interesting to see where I'm going you
know as as where my life's at and uh
looking forward to
an Oliveira or chief Allen or
my Creator right
you know I'm not pissed at him you know
all these all he's doing is saying hey I
want you and I'm leading you here and uh
to keep your ears open yeah what's your
instructors pay attention
right
so do that with my fibroids pay
attention I'd look at them sometime but
when this guy Lieutenant roses goes to
the chief said yeah he says what'd you
do do what's his name I said I didn't do
anything to him what's up he said well I
came over and says I think the chief
hates me he says why is that it's
because he just looked at me
and I felt it
says no and that comes from instructors
right it comes from the Oliveira look it
comes from Chief Allen it comes from an
instructor going
it just lives
and uh he said I just told him that's
your face sometimes
that's what you look like well Gil uh
any other closing thoughts
no I I just want to thank you I
appreciate the opportunity I go
um that that I'm here I was pretty
apprehensive about it I wasn't quite
sure but then it it just uh
um
I'm grateful to the Creator that you're
here and that that we're here together
and I'm glad I'm glad you made it
through
and just
I'm just pray a blessing on you and
nickel well um thank you definitely
appreciate it um definitely you know
blessed to be here as we all are
um and and just thank you thank you for
you know thank you for laying that
groundwork in the teams the the the
groundwork that you guys that that we
built off of that we tried to maintain
the the reputation that you guys earned
and and we always did our best so thank
you for doing that thank you for your
service and in the Navy and the teams
and of course 30 how many years as a
firefighter 37 37 years yeah as a
firefighter
um and
just that that level of service uh can't
thank you enough appreciate you coming
thank you yeah
and with that Gil Espinoza has left the
building
and
I think makes it pretty clear that
getting after it is a lifelong Mission
yes
it's a lifelong Mission and you know it
was very interesting and awesome to hear
somebody that's been doing all kinds of
things badass things from being a seal
in Vietnam to being a firefighter to be
in a a wrestler
at a really high level
and he's 75 years old and he's like I'm
still trying to figure it out so
pretty awesome oh yeah the parts that
stood out to me which is funny
is the Black Mac and pink mac oh yeah
and you're like why you call them
blackback I was like bro I know exactly
right
because he's black yeah so interesting
well you take that that is the that is
the uh assumption and it's a it's a
correct assumption to make oh and seeing
the teams whatever whatever like if
you're a Mexican you're gonna have some
kind of Mexican nickname if you're black
not guaranteed but most likely you're
gonna have some kind of something that
has to do with your ethnicity yeah makes
sense uh because it's like that's just
that's just how that's just how uh well
in Hawaii I tell you this before in
Hawaii race racial issues is not a thing
not a big deal at all everybody's mixed
and they're so and there's so many races
or whatever so to say oh the Filipino
guy oh the black guy or popolo guy you
say popolo in for a black guy or the
Holly guy or the Japanese guy or
whatever like that's not a thing no
one's like oh that's racial or nothing
there's no racial sensitivity
you know why because everybody's
something
um
so
I get it but so I get that that kind of
like commit where if it's funny that
they called pink Mac baby because
you know like I said no he's a black guy
I'm telling you bro he didn't eat
nothing he did not look black yeah you
know he might have had a black mom but
he didn't look black and he's from the
island so he seemed like a howling guy
that just you know
but that's the thing too though if
you're like if you're Hoppa like that
and you're half black and you just pull
the white side A lot of times you wind
up with freckles oh yeah there's this
guy one of my friends from college
Gerald Lacy white guy Holly guy half
black his older brother is like dark
skin he's like a white dude
he didn't talk like white dude he's from
Crenshaw but to look at him you're like
and he had freckles they call him uh I
think
my dad used to always say this call this
red bone when you're real real
light-skinned black person red bone
forever
um also okay for the black thing in
white thing so my brother Jade's
nickname when he was young was snake
right and there's a guy in the teams
that you know I don't I think he's still
in Soto say his name but his name is
snake too because he has a lisp
and he's a twin too by the way but so
when we moved here uh so Jeremy my
friend Jeremy he'd always teased Jade
call him snake because that's his little
nickname from you know when you're a
little kid to tease him
so when we moved here we met snake he's
a white guy blonde hair blue-eyed dude
so but there's Jade
who's black half black then there's
snake who's white so Jade was black
snake this guy was white snake
same exact thing so I understood exactly
what this guy's black mark this guy's so
pink that's another level yeah kind of
funny so I dug it I mean I understood
yeah yeah I mean it was wasn't like I
was surprising he's like oh he's black I
was like okay yeah okay but it could
have also been like some random story
about you know oh we call them black Mac
because he you know he got gunpowder on
the blah blah blah you know just
whatever but but it's a good nickname so
I figured we had to get to the bottom of
that one there you go
um but anyways what an awesome uh
opportunity to hear from a guy that's
been through all kinds of stuff and and
is still out there trying to learn so
staying active that's for sure yeah yeah
for sure yeah he's like saying oh yeah
my shoulders like jam but when you're
looking at 75 years old when you look at
me like bro this guy's like
she looks what do you how old is how
does how old does he look if he said he
was sick if he said he was 55 I wouldn't
be like oh yeah I'd be okay cool yeah
you know you look like you're aging a
little bit yeah yeah looks like you look
like you've been rode pretty hard but at
55 you're still doing pretty good but
then he's like no I'm 75. I would look
at his body and be like oh you're 55
dang you're still getting after it yeah
for sure obviously for sure that's
literally what he looks like yeah
impressive so hey pays man stay active
you know stay in the game probably that
that's gotta have something to do with
just staying humble you know you know
what I'm saying yeah you're not like
taking it for granted yeah yeah you know
when mentally you stay in the game who
is one of the I think
this guy Tom he's a wrestler here he
trains very easy anyway he he said
something really important where he was
like yeah my dad he would like
he said there was something along the
lines of uh don't give yourself like the
excuse of age to start going less hard
or whatever hey look if you can't go
hard you can't go hard yeah like if
you're trying to lift your max or
whatever and you can't get it then okay
you can't get it but don't be like hey
you know I'm 70 now or probably a lot of
times it starts younger so hey I'm 40
now so I'm gonna instead of getting this
hard set of 10 with you know 100 pounds
or whatever
dumbbells
I'm gonna do like 80s and see what I'm
saying just because I'm getting older
now kind of a thing and look I'm not
saying go crazy and be dangerous I'm not
saying that but that mindset of like hey
I'm gonna cut I'm gonna cut myself some
slack
because I'm getting older just in
general is not that good of an idea
where it seems like
like he wasn't you know Gil like didn't
do that he's like straight yeah oh yeah
no slack he's like 75 he's like you know
I'm really looking forward to like you
know really developing and you know like
my brothers most people 75 bro that's
like you
but yeah so you can just tell by them um
that he has that mindset you know and it
shows right on awesome well speaking of
staying in the game yeah got to stay in
the game get yourself some Jocko fuel to
stay in the game get yourself some joint
warfare that's the thing that's going to
keep you in the game well let me
rephrase that that's the thing that's
Gonna Knock You Out of the game is when
the joints break down when the joints
break down we break down
the machine breaks down it's true so you
got to be careful that one uh
jocklefuel.com you can get it there you
can get it at Wawa you can get Vitamin
Shoppe you get everything at Vitamin
Shoppe you can get the military
commissaries Hannafords
Dash stores up in Maryland wake Fern and
ShopRite Circle K in Florida HEB and
Tejas
Murphy's down the southeast and Meyer in
the midwest that's where you can get
this
fuel for you
that's good for you that's the key
component
so there you go also you know wrestling
yeah he was coaching wrestling for four
years that's going to keep you in the
game Jiu Jitsu is going to keep you in
the game yeah
so you should train Jiu Jitsu when you
train Jiu Jitsu you're gonna need some
gear to train Jiu-Jitsu and you're gonna
need a ghee
rash guards shorts originusa.com
originusa.com go there get whatever you
need get hunt gear
get jeans we do we got to talk about the
Delta 68. the funny thing see here's the
thing he's like oh we didn't wear those
because they were
he said there's no operational purpose
and I was like oh just to be cool he's
like it wasn't even to be cool there it
was to be cool back in America right now
I'm gonna say this
I'm going to make this statement if they
would have had Delta 68s that we make
they would have preferred to wear those
oh yeah 100 because they're they're
light they got they got a little bit of
stretch my fatigue don't stretch yeah
like fatigue jungle Camis they don't
stretch at all
68's got that little bit of give you a
little leeway not it's not even a little
it's all the leeway that you need to
move you want to do a squat you can do
it you want to do a front kick you can
do it so the Delta 68s re-engineered
yeah if we could get time travel we go
back in time and just drop off Seal Team
One Seal Team two they're out there in
the Delta give them some Delta 68s here
you go boys yeah so Let Freedom ride
wait so just to clarify and this was one
of the cooler things that I've heard too
one of many small but very cool so he
was saying you wear them in combat just
so they're almost like got their street
cred when you come back where it's like
versus jeans are the ones that I wore
you know it's not like you can wear your
helmet or your night vision goggles I'm
just saying you know and be like yeah
these are the ones that are probably why
you're gonna wear that but jeans you
can't have you seen pictures with guys
that are carrying like Flags like rolled
up on their gear they'll carry like an
American flag like on their gear like a
full American flag it's the same kind of
thing it's like hey this has been on Ops
with me right you know I have the little
the little American flag on my body
armor that's like my favorite flag you
know little American flag that
went out on Ops with me that's what it
did so let me ask you this and this is
maybe I'm out of touch but so you know
how they they would wear jeans right can
is that even possible now could you ever
go on like totally oh for real yeah I
think we're Delta 68s all day oh damn
like on a real yeah World op Mission
whatever damn okay I mean sometimes you
wear civilian clothes on missions I've
done it you know yeah
low visibility operations right what I'm
saying yeah yeah Andy if you really I
mean if you really wanted to you could
wear them in the SEAL Teams you can get
away with a lot
now look if you're in ramadi and you
start mix and matching uniforms in 2006
and somebody sees you and you don't look
like a American that's not a good call
look you want to look like an American
Soldier or Marine 100 I understand so
yeah there you go all that stuff origin
USA made in America from the dirt to the
shirt
that's what we're doing originusa.com
get it true also Jocko store
Jocko's store
go to jackalstore.com this link was here
shirts
hats hoodies
some new stuff got shirt Locker which is
a new shirt every month a lot of people
like this one for real they really like
this one um uh you know a little bit
different designs but you get a new
shirt every month
um so yeah you can subscribe on there
too for that as well jacostar.com
subscribe to that subscribe to the
podcast subscribe to the Jocko
underground getting ready to record a
couple of those right now give some
people some backside information about
the world answer questions so doc
underground.com if you want to get
involved with that we got the YouTube
channels we got psychological warfare
flip side canvas Dakota Meyer I've
written a bunch of books hey the the
beginning today I read from by water
beneath the walls I was just at the Seal
Team One reunion I'm with guys I'm with
plank owners meaning I'm with guys at
the Seal Team One reunion that were the
first guys they were there when Seal
Team One started they were there and all
these Vietnam guys were we were talking
about this book and guys were like oh
there's so much information that I
didn't even know people that started
Seal Team One we're like I learned so
Ben Milligan by water beneath the walls
get it it's just an unbelievable uh book
and then of course only cry for the
living by Holly McKay that's another
book about war get you get you some
insight into human nature and then of
course I've written a bunch of books so
you can get some of those books as well
Echelon front
leadership consultancy we saw problems
through leadership so if you want to
help your company your business your
team go to ashlandfront.com if you want
to come to one of our Live Events check
out the events that we have also we have
the academy where we teach leadership
online we got online recorded courses we
do live training on there extreme
ownership.com
if you want to help out service members
active and retired you want to help out
their families gold star families check
out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee She's Got
That charity organization you heard
about what it did for Gill today so get
get involved in that at America's Mighty
Warriors dot org and then of course we
have Drago's organization which is Navy
sealsfund.org and then Heroes and horses
dot org so those are some uh good
Charities if you want to help the people
that help us
and also if you want to hang out with
Echo and I
um on Twitter on the gram on Facebook
Twitter's reignited there's lots of
people jumping on Twitter right now some
people are leaving I don't know what's
happening I've been there I'm still
there we'll see where it goes but no
matter where you are on the social media
world watch out for that algorithm
because it'll sneak up and grab you by
the throat
and you're not gonna like that
uh so
that's that uh one more thank you to Gil
Espinoza for joining us today thank you
Gil
for your life of service to the Navy to
the teams and to the fire department we
all thank you for that and thanks to all
the firefighters out there
all the firefighters out there on call
keeping us safe
ready to sacrifice your safety rate of
sacrifice your life for us and our
families
thank you to all the firefighters out
there and the same goes to our EMTs
paramedics and of course police law
enforcement dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all First Responders thank you for
keeping us safe on the home front and
by
with certainty thank you to the folks in
military uniform who go out protect
freedom and liberty around the world we
are eternally grateful for the
protection that you provide us and
everyone else out there
like Gil learned during basic SEAL
training all those years ago
you can't change the water temperature
of the ocean
it's going to be what it's going to be
so don't complain don't whine don't
grumble
instead just go and get after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko out